[Music]
Batman Beyond I'm Kevin Smith I'm not
Bernardo Oh
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the
[ __ ] petri dish that is the scum and
villainy cantina man which is on
Hollywood Boulevard in Hollywood
California put your hands ago those are
the folks at home no you were real when
they to our populations dead where were
you at the end of days you were here
that's true we ended our lives in a
[ __ ] bar where it began getting
lately so true the welcome ladies
gentlemen we are in the intrepid few who
are still willing to brave the world and
go out there and stuff like that I was
gonna be in South by Southwest next week
but they canceled that event not so much
yeah it's not gonna happen so it's
delightful that we're actually there's
someplace that's not canceling events
yet and stuff cut to next week like
[ __ ] hot zone is scum and villainy
Cantina [ __ ] 50 cases Snake Plissken
to come in and get us nobody else will
go in they got that going on right now
in New York in like New Rochelle they
quarantine an entire section where
there's a bunch of cases and whatnot and
they're not letting people in or out
that [ __ ] is like The Blob son like it
is very right now we're living in like a
sci-fi movie and [ __ ] like that
never mind like watching contagion if
you gave that a spun recently no because
I don't hate myself that much that was
the first thing I thought of though
whenever they started talking about this
I was like that sounds like that
contagion movie and then also it was
like the number one movie on iTunes and
[ __ ] I'm like we all have the same
thought but right now all still above
ground and stuff like that and just for
[ __ ] strawpoll anybody in the room
carrying the virus right now
cover your mouth wash your hand wash
your hands
yeah yes
again the worst part is that there's
gonna be when it's all said and done
like stop washing their hands like it's
cured I need to do this fight of the day
anymore I don't even need to use the
three shells I can just wipe my ass with
my hands [ __ ] it I've seen so many
instructional videos that actually like
taught me a thing or [ __ ] to them and
there was one where the people were like
this is how people wash their hands we
show you how badly they wash their hands
by washing our hands with paint and so
they wash their as the fainting just did
but essentially I've done my whole life
which is like and then done and the hand
was like there was paint here and the
rest of it was all uncovered and it was
like holy [ __ ] that's horrifying
so now I've been like really like
washing my hands and singing happy
birthday twice
I'm sure well I mean dude you could do
the the litany of fear from doing that
also times out shall not fear fear is
the mind killer fears a little death
that brings total obliteration I will
face my fear allow it to pass over me
and through me and when it is gone only
I shall remain hands are clean that's
awesome
the only problem is I would have to [ __ ]
and learn that happy birthdays it's
right there yeah cuz I when I'm washing
my hands I'm like [ __ ] them all Madhu
Silent Bob speaking of which I just got
back done not too long ago finished 65
City Tour J saw Bobby even wrote short
oh yes [ __ ] beast it's crazy man I
saw some rock star denounced the [ __ ]
tour like a month ago they look we're
doing 30 days I was like [ __ ] the I was
there for every one of them and I think
Jamie was there for 59 of them how am I
need you go to 2020 of 65 months and one
of you got paid for them I know I had to
be there was your [ __ ] excuse it was
wonderful I will miss it every [ __ ]
day of my life and it's nice to be home
nice to be here and stuff but it was
just you know I said it many times in
the road and Jamie heard it many [ __ ]
times Jeremy
it was like going to church to a church
every night where I was both the priest
and Jesus at the same time oh it's
[ __ ] fantastic man and we just drove
like every day four five six hours real
punk rock man it was like in an SUV and
stuff and every night went to a place
where like a thousand people were so
happy to see us and watch the moving
[ __ ] it was really really [ __ ]
delightful and I'm you know I was bummed
when it ended it inspired the [ __ ] out
of me we're in as much as like now I
know that's how I want to do clerkes
three like I want to pay for the whole
[ __ ] thing myself and then take it
out on tour and just live on the road
with it for like a year man like cuz I
did four months and it was nothing like
if time went by so quickly
and we made so much money if if we did
that for like a year
oh my god and all that money would be
mine so like now I'm like that's the
dream and it's also kind of [ __ ] punk
rock to be like I said my children want
a divorce yeah we're good we're done
we're on the road for a year and then
two years but I would do it differently
this time like I would build in we'd be
on the road for like four weeks and then
a week down four weeks in a week down so
like I'd be able to come back and stuff
but oh my god the for the guy who
started his career like very DIY like
I'm gonna make this [ __ ] myself to like
finish that trilogy and make that movie
myself and then like schlep it that was
my dream with clerks like that's what I
thought I was gonna have to do
I'd finance the movie on credit cards
and then I'd have to for wallet rent
theaters and [ __ ] convince people to
come see and [ __ ] and then mercifully it
went another way but now I'm like oh my
god it's my destiny to do it like I was
always meant to do it now that being
said I'm glad I'm not doing it right the
[ __ ] now man because every day I thank
God we just finished the reboot or just
as the whole world was like and we're
about to hibernate for a year straight
because it's gonna be tough to get
people to go out for a little while man
so it was a fantastic [ __ ] tour
that's why I'm not really scared of the
coronavirus obviously I'm not in one of
the high-risk groups and stuff but I
just spent
like out for the last four months I've
been in 65 cities three countries some
more than the 65 cities 60 67 [ __ ]
cities three countries during which time
like I saw tons of [ __ ] people every
night including like we did pictures
after the screening hugging [ __ ]
people taking pictures I'll get him
again and off they went
so I interact and Jason Mewes is like a
massive germaphobe and he was just like
don't touch me cuz I was always like
hugging everybody and [ __ ] and he was
like when you get your jacket
dry-cleaned and I was like wine he's
like you touching everybody all those
germs and she'll like that never [ __ ]
occurred to me once I didn't even get a
[ __ ] cold on the road
nor did I get the flu and [ __ ] so I
think my my immune system is functioning
like really high right now and the
hidden gift to that tour was I think it
probably [ __ ] strengthened it because
that's me like interacting with a bunch
of germs man like weather people in
general I'm given [ __ ] if they were
washed in there and super good or not
that's a lot of [ __ ] bodies to come
in contact with and so far I haven't
been felled by anything so I'm ready to
[ __ ] go right into that hot zone and
help [ __ ] man I don't think I
could catch it the only thing left for
you now is to be dipped in the grotto at
the Playboy Mansion
like [ __ ] Achilles by your heels yes
like because if you're looking for the
pit of germs that kill [ __ ] so
much [ __ ] is in that garage I believe
that's where they're looking for the
Vipers cure
formulate the inoculation from the pool
we can still got semen in here if we get
it back out do you think they're gonna
find the cure and semen I don't think
you understand the corona virus mark I
don't think you understand Sonny Sonny
Corleone semen that's true powerful
[Laughter]
that's been mating with rosey Grier's
semen that's been mating with Harrison
Ford semen that's been mating with like
pull somebody from the 90s part the 90s
those 80s butts nice little pull hard I
wear my sunglasses
I was about to say if I get no he
wouldn't have been in that grotto you
given this way more thought than I it's
like somebody asked me a question yeah
oh my god this is the realest question
of the night let your celebrities who
would have been in the grotto in 1994
Eddie Murphy he's been in that grotto
for 45 years
he's got 87 children he does have a lot
of [ __ ] kids I think he's been too
busy to be in the Playboy grotto making
family and stuff ever an article where
he was like cuz you know somebody was
like what did what were you doing like
you know we seem to go away for a little
while and he said I just wanted to he's
like I was working since I was 17 he's
like and I did my first movie when I was
like 21 or something like that he's gone
I just wanted to sit on the couch and be
a dad and I guess that happens too like
everybody like could you imagine like
the Eddie Murphy's dreams came true at a
young age and it went beyond his [ __ ]
dreams and even he got to a point where
is like you know what I'm tired I mean I
prefer that version to like cloning
dinosaurs of the like idle rich dude was
like what I'm gonna do just make some
babies and raise them cost is no object
so I got to get another job I can hire
all the help that I need it's like now
I'm gonna [ __ ] make dinosaurs Jon
Hamm in this [ __ ] because I'm bored and
rich so hey my preference the assertion
here is thank God Eddie Murphy didn't
want to make dinosaurs thank God that
sounds like a [ __ ] comedy he should
have made man what have you been up to
I've been busy I'm in busy I got any job
what is it well first let me tell you
what the old job was because I hadn't
been able to talk about the old job but
I'm still not able to but I quit it
so I kind of don't care that much you
had a job that you quit I had a job that
I quit to take another job that I just
started the job that I quit yeah the
show that I had been able to talk about
for like four months now I was on the
Continental and that's the show that's
as the John wick and the John wick were
about the hotel for assassins
from the wick averse for the wick averse
yes that's totally not what we call it
wick world which sounds worse whip girls
it's actually cute hmm yeah it's been 20
weeks trying to build story set in the
hotel about about maybe John wick maybe
not John wick I don't know if it gets
weird we'll just cut this from the
podcast but you guys get to know sexy
talk about to work blue for a sagging
hood but I was super fun like it's you
get to do all the things that I love to
do which is take a take a piece of IP
and find new stories to tell in a world
that you're kind of familiar with and
and find new nooks and crannies and find
new ways to dramatize what are
ultimately classic stories there's only
you know what 37 some are dramatic
situations in the world maybe that yeah
that's a lot it feels like it but there
was a book called the 37 dramatic
situations which lists every kind of
permutation of story you could mix them
together whatever but there's 37 but to
pick one but like what's this one is
revenge this one is homecoming this one
is man versus nature this one is you
know tragedy this one is heartbreak like
there's modes of stories a big one that
fits in that kind of world it was super
great and all set in the hotel we
allowed to leave the premises we could
leave the premises it was it was less
about being in the hotel room like sort
of the world that the hotel will sort of
create right and and and feed and in
some cases cannibalize on I saw was
super fun like it was a really good time
but but then I got a call from the
future and there was like hey do you
want to listen Starfleet and I said [ __ ]
yet I do
so I started yesterday on Star Trek
Picard Oh which is the craziest [ __ ]
thing you're a Star Trek kid right the
very way you posted that script I saw
the script covered is something like a
spec script you wrote what is that that
was when I was in college there was a
writing for a TV competition mm-hmm
that was sponsored by Google Productions
which doesn't exist anymore but they
made
back in the day Ubu sit good dog um and
and they've sponsored this writing
competition when my professors were like
hey men like you shouldn't do this like
you're a pretty decent writer you know
you have a you have a capacity for this
you should enter this competition that
says well I don't want very much TV and
you had to write a sample episode of a
show to enter and say we must watch
something and I said well the only thing
I'll watch this [ __ ] Star Trek and he
said well then write a Star Trek so he
did so I sat down I wrote a next
generation episode because that was my
Star Trek at the time was next gen sort
of automation racially I'm sorry I sent
it off into the wilderness and then like
six months later I get his envelope in
the mail that says hey you won you won
the Ubu contest I won the stand Ubu
stand
good boy and yeah and so they sent me
out to LA for a summer between my junior
and senior years of college and I in
turn the Paramount a lot Oh
Ubu had a show that was up and running
at the time called Brooklyn Bridge yeah
with with mrs. Cunningham this is Gary
Dave Goldberg show indeed and so I
interned on that for a couple Marion
Ross that was their name I don't want to
reduce her [ __ ] character missus kind
of got Marion Ross but yeah we know that
was a very acclaimed show so you saw
some of the making of that channel a
little bit like they were that most of
the scripts have been written and they
were in production at the time and they
were like hey listen we should maybe put
you on a show where there's actual
writing being done I happen to this is
Gary
- Tommy he's like I happen to know Rick
Berman is running the Star Trek stuff
that's just across the lot do you want
to go do that
I said yeah man I wanted to do that and
so it was the the summer when they were
starting season 5 of next generation
they were shooting times arrow I think
was the the premiere and they were
starting to deep space 9
mmm literally like they just built the
first sets they'd shot a pilot where
they were just up and running and they
were building the writers room and
setting to listen to pitches and I got
to sit in on all of that and it was
phenomenal and super instructive in
educating and illuminating and then I
went and had a life that was 20 years
not doing Star Trek and did you wait did
you work on Deep Space nine yeah I was
in I was helping take notes I was
reading script Star Trek was the only
show in the history of TV that had open
policy where you could be from anywhere
in the world and write a script and sent
it to Star Trek and they would consider
it
did they ever shoot a script from
mirando yeah did they really well Jane
Espenson got her start Janice mancine
who worked on Buffy and Angel and
Firefly and she wrote a spec script
ascended to Star Trek and they bought it
and they brought her in and she pitched
other ideas Ron Moore who created
Battlestar Galactica entered that way a
friend of mine Jose Molina wrote a
script for Star Trek and got invited to
be an intern and then started a TV
career it happened all the time but way
more than you would think you'd think so
wait you were working as a writers
assistant I was reading script because
the interns all got to read the slush
pile of like here's the like nine year
old tall stack of scripts we got this
week somebody's got to read these I'm
sorry you're sitting there like oh man
this sucks but I got or not say that it
sucks in the way that it really does I
got to leave some hope and so yeah well
your script wasn't great you might want
to think about oh my god you were doing
fat man beyond even back then yes I was
crude they needed me to be like this
scripts great they needed you to be like
give it out the button but yeah and like
it got to the point where when I left
and went back to college which I liked
my dad wasn't my parents were not nearly
as cool as yours where were you're like
I'm dropping out of school and I'm gonna
be a filmmaker and I was a I'm dropping
out school to be a TV writer they said
no you're not finishing college and so I
finished college and then became mature
and listened and then it was about 20 to
be fair when I finally told my parents I
want to be a filmmaker I was 22 so it's
not Larry you weren't like 20 years old
I know but there I was living in their
house so they could have said no but at
the end of the day they were like oh let
him do it to get it out of his system
and then he'll be a waiter well yeah and
so now is literally what my mother said
you'll be a waiter yeah those they
thought they were out the she was like
he could be a waiter like your brother
they there was no you know my parents
didn't come from a world where it's like
oh you're clever you should do something
with that it was just like oh you're
clever go wash the dishes
so you know it was Shawn it took him a
minute
like once clerks got picked up my mother
you know but I've said many times when
she first saw it her reaction to it was
like you spent $27,000 on this piece of
garbage and then the movie got picked up
and you know she's at the premiere on
Entertainment Tonight going like you
know there's some harsh language in it
but like you know it's very good and my
son is you know she became a fan and now
she's hands down like my biggest fan in
the world and stuff but yeah in the
beginning not necessarily so much I
didn't know that about Star Trek that
anybody could just [ __ ] write it and
that was that was a Gene Roddenberry
edict is that he felt the show the
franchise in a great part the fact that
they got to make a next generation was
because fans believed in the show as
much as they did right and so they
should be able to if they were qualified
and talented enough take part in that
success and maybe use that as part of
their creating their own futures it's
[ __ ] sweet and like for anybody out
there watching just in case you guys
want to do your own fat man beyond send
us a script will [ __ ] consider it
that's Rob know it's rotten bury that
[ __ ] man pick them Roddenberry's you
just need to hire an intern to Rito's
pick them Roddenberry yes you think the
hospitai blind eye was Lucille Ball
that's right well deuce to the original
introduced they never would have been
able to make it without without them and
apparently she wasn't like a big Lucy
wasn't a big sci-fi fan but she was just
like other sounds good and kind of went
with it I can't render the stars sure
that could make money and that [ __ ] up
man like because Lucy was like all right
like like Star Trek is still a [ __ ]
thing yep JJ Abrams would not have ever
directed a Star Wars movie if not like
Lucille Ball hadn't been like yeah
[ __ ] Star Trek
it's crazy man that is an interesting
causality loop that she just built
though
well apparently you owe your [ __ ]
latest success to Lucille Ball as well
so you better be like I Love Lucy
it's like astronauts and scientists and
like [ __ ] Nobel Prize where she's
like you know what Star Trek is my jam
you're like yeah I mean we get flip
phones I guess I'll just watch Star Trek
I guarantee you talk to most astronauts
to be like do you want to go to space or
do you want to be JJ Abrams it'd be like
how much does that guy make [ __ ] space I
was there there's no money in space wait
a second so go back to getting the job
how does this happen
it happens because I got a [ __ ] DM on
Instagram from I know like somebody slid
into my DMS was like hey you up
you want a ripe Picard yeah you wanna go
to the final frontier like yeah baby
what are you wearing I'm wearing my for
Pips on McCauley you got four pips on
your collar you a [ __ ] commander no
it's not I'm a captain the DM was like
you up number one doing number two well
yeah I'd like to 69 number one so what
happened to make it so engage house late
into your DMS the guy who's running
season two of the card
a guy named Terry metallus who did
twelve Monkeys and was on MacGyver the
this past season I think was like hey
are you working now and I said yeah I'm
a continental he was like oh oh the one
from Saturday Night Live I'm like no no
not that confident oh my god that's deep
god right there and now the Continental
and it's like well when are you when are
you done and I told him when my contract
ended for for the continental he's like
well are you a Star Trek fan it was like
yeah man I'm a Star Trek fan no really I
got this and she was like well if you're
interested like that's come in and sit
down and we'll talk okay so I went down
there I met with Terry and he's like wow
how big a star fan are you so well when
I was in college I taught myself how to
play the inner light theme from the
episode where Patrick Stewart jean-luc
Picard gets sucked into a sort of probe
that gives him an 80 year life and they
were like security hold on security we
got okay we're fine but yeah I dropped
my deep Star Trek bona fides and he was
like hey listen man if you want to come
and play I was like I would love to you
don't know you don't know love to put
some [ __ ] in Picard's mouths words and
other things maybe what else chocolates
French I got a whole sex rap for him
ready
and so like about a month after that
where there was like more meetings and
meeting with executives at CBS and
meeting with more people and so anything
as simple as like [ __ ] I got a DM and
I got a job yeah you had to meet with
some people still rather you still gotta
like do the you made it sound easy I was
like oh maybe one day somebody will pop
up in my DMS and I'll get a TV show and
[ __ ] it sounds like the same old
[ __ ] you gotta go talk to people and
impress them and show them you got an
idea
sure them at you wear pants when you
show up for me yeah [ __ ] that
I don't wear pants and it's the wait you
ran the gauntlet and if I ran the GALT
everyone approved made it through the
other side apparently there was some
some vetting that Terry did and talking
to old bosses and old colleagues and old
friends and asking about you and asking
about me really and apparently all the
checks that I send those [ __ ]
paid off because they all said nice
things I can yeah so when it you have
you been in the room yet yeah today was
day two so Brandi knew really yeah Wow
how many people in the room 9 I think
including myself and sooner like me so
right now they're breaking stories for
season 2 yeah
so presumably within the next 6 months
you're gonna write a sentence for Picard
and then he's gonna say it he's gonna
say that [ __ ] you're good that's [ __ ]
you're about to command the commander of
a [ __ ] former commander of a starship
and I'm what did they do in season 1
have they what's the it is it is very
much like Picard who had been retired
and living in his dotage in a chateau in
France you know it's the old gunslinger
putting his guns back on getting called
back into the field
why didn't get called back in there's a
very complex to Star Trek isn't about
them easy stories but it's huh it's like
data might have had a daughter who comes
to see Picard and says my life is in
danger but cars like [ __ ] yeah
saddle up and he goes into like space
difficulty honestly that sounds more
exciting than Trade Federation
yeah there's less less about taxation
blockades yeah yeah [ __ ] it's more
engaging all right so he's pulled out of
mothballs did they bring everybody else
out there they're they're parsing out
the so one per episode like it's her
it's him so it's all data in the trailer
so for you meat data you meet Will Riker
you meet Deanna Troi
seven of nine from Voyager I saw her and
that's a crossover right yeah never on
the other was on the Voyager show what
about they're gonna bring back Wesley or
no I don't know come on how could you
not I mean I do but I can't say oh my
god I was speculating but you [ __ ]
know I couldn't know whatever we say
here if it winds up in the show you'll
owe us money I say it here and it comes
out oh my god I forgot that you were
just talking about how you worked on the
show we're sitting here I'm about to go
like down the rabbit hole like do you
think the brain wants a bastard and
you're like I don't know ringless yeah
do you want us to bring Wesley
hold on hey man we should maybe bring
Wesley back so that's [ __ ] dope how
did you know the dude the DM do you
bleed your friends is that all it was
all it was todd stashwick is a buddy of
mine who co-hosted a black man be on
with me well you were off in the
wilderness he was on 12 monkeys and
we're just mutual buddies once again
it's about who you [ __ ] know in this
ten it is about who you know and who you
you are not an [ __ ] to that's very
very true that's the important part
nobody ever tells you that is [ __ ]
dope man [ __ ] Wow look at you alright
will this job ever be a conflict you
think with what like we can't touch to
our Trek or Picard then right like we
can't even speculate if a trailer plays
you can't even you can't even talk about
it I could say wow that looks good right
yeah like we can sit there and talk
about like the west-world trails that
you realize I spent more in the
west-world trailer than they spend on
those movies and I gotta get men save
about Picard is that true have you seen
the West world trailer yeah but I mean
isn't the trailer made up of all footage
from the what they spent more on the
[ __ ] show than they spend yeah it
looks like a terminator - yeah it's very
very impressive but honestly like it's
been so long that I thought I was out of
loop on that as I go I haven't watched
that show in seasons but it's only
season 3 yeah so I've just haven't
watched season 2 so now I'll go back and
watch season 2 do you need to well I'd
need to in order to it probably couldn't
hurt but I hope they would make it to
the new people who didn't maybe watch
the crappy season two can pick up with
season 3 they're smart I like to believe
they're smart fair enough and that's how
you get jobs on cool shows by [ __ ]
on other shows one must choose is so
true I watched a show recently I watched
The Outsider do you like The Outsider
are you watching it I am two episodes
behind but I'm
I'm kind of the way there I'm with you
like you liking it no oh really
yeah well here's the thing that show the
first two episodes I was [ __ ] in on
it right the the Jason Bateman baton
switchmen the baton Bateman and switch
yes I thought was pretty great yes but
then like I figured out what it was give
or take by episode three and you're
watching a show with characters who are
supposed to be smart who either can't
figure it out or won't listen to the one
lady who has figured it out right and so
you like why is it really so [ __ ]
dumb and I just it bothers me when I'm
this far ahead and I don't think I'm the
only one who's as far ahead in it so oh
no I yeah no this is no-brainer like I
get it I was well made and I was with it
every step of the way but the last
episode is yeah you're like oh that's it
yeah it's just like it's pretty I
thought they built very very nicely but
then at the end it's like what else are
you gonna do especially like at one
point I sitting there watching it and
again I thought everybody did a great
job but I was like oh it's it again like
they're going into a cave to fight a
monster that's got no [ __ ] form but
he can look like other people and stuff
you know but I say that as if [ __ ]
Stephen King ever saw anything I ever
did he'd be like oh it's clerks again
[ __ ] you yeah but it did feel very
similar it felt like it felt like it
without a clown no yeah well I mean it
it feels like it should have been a
movie and not a show and it needed to be
a show it needed to not be ten episodes
long because all the taffy yeah it's
trying to sustain more than I think that
story has the energy to sustain so
you're like oh all right let's talk
about this lady now who's a real estate
agent who now decides to sue the police
why do I care about this lady's real
estate agency issues and her litigation
plan like I don't I want to know who
[ __ ] killed these children right I
get so every now and again they are not
putting the camera on the story the
audience is interested in in an effort
to kind of like Buffy
a world that we're not that crazy about
it's weird man I'm so not a demanding
viewer like that never occurred to me I
was like all right like the pace they're
telling the story and like honestly what
I do is I watch something like that and
I'm like oh I suck it my job cuz it
would never occur to me to do something
like this this seems classy but what
you're telling me is you're sitting
there going like this is [ __ ] boring
it's like be more entertaining like
[ __ ] dope you know what I did watch
it love what high fidelity how is it
it's so [ __ ] good man it's crazy
funny episodes it's ten episodes
half-hour each episode and is it how
does it relate to the movie there are
it's it's a loose adaptation of the book
and unless the movie it's more about the
book that is the movie but it drops a
lot of what is now in hindsight kind of
weird toxic masculinity on the part of
John Cusack's character where like he is
so inward flexing and he so everything
becomes a list and that's his virtue and
also his downfall but that he begins
ranking women according to some like it
just gets very oddly sexist and
misogynistic in ways that the TV show
finds ways to subvert because the main
character is now Lisa Bonet prime which
is so [ __ ] weird looking at zoe
kravitz because every now and again you
look at stole her identity for a second
thing yeah but like you look at her so
no she's her mom in the original yeah
that's cute yeah she's not related she's
playing John Cusack scary right yeah
every not again you look at her it's oh
[ __ ] that's [ __ ] Lisa Bonet and then
she just turns her head and said now
what so did Kravitz and she's great
never mind that that's Catwoman right
there it's Catwoman there's Lana calm
and I saw a picture of her with the
haircut and I was like oh that looks
like you know me now yeah looks like
Selina Kyle but high fidelity is great
like it's it is it is all about sort of
the the inward damage that one does when
they're not sure who they're supposed to
be even though if you're living where
exactly where you're supposed to live in
a time where you're supposed to live you
found
thing you want to do which is I want to
help bring people joy through music but
I'm obsessive about it and and she's she
sabotages herself in the most
interesting ways
when's its president yeah current day
there's still at a record shop which I
buy give him the resurgence of vinyl
yeah I get it but yeah it's still very
much like when a record shop they they
cast the woman who was in Bowfinger the
female lead in dolomite dolomite is my
name
Oh divine joy Randolph is that her name
the one who was that his friend who was
like his confidante sexy black friend
though she is a really wonderful scene
and in dolomite as my name when she like
when he's talking about not wanting to
do the sexy and this is the same actress
I'm talking about when she's just like
make it funny make it funny really like
warm beautiful Diller she did a great
job yeah movie that's what that whole
movie is fantastic she's the Jack Black
character I'll get at it yeah so she's
the like the crazy loud like swinging
into the [ __ ] record store and she's
amazing she's great I'm in ya know it's
it's what it's it is the girls that I
was one of girls to be but never was and
I wanted to like girls a lot
oh you mean girls the show not girls in
general about the in the choir that
all-girl diff why can't all women be
like these women I mean I know you're
all different different but be different
this way the way that I wanted to types
so then I can rank you like I'm gonna
like him that corny novel that what he
did in the book did you ever read the
book I did read the book and you know I
read it at a time when I was also should
he do and and then got older was the
book good it is good to treat the book
because of the movie yeah because you
like to move it yeah yeah I went back
how close was the book to the movie yeah
not quite I mean the spirit is the same
but the book is set in London and the
movies in Chicago how close is the
series to the book wildly different in
ways and then very specifically the same
in ways what's
New York shows in New York and it's very
much about that New York and it's about
that in New York and what it's like
being like 30 something with a little
bit of money and no real attachments and
the life that you can live this sort of
weird awesome nomad bougie bohemian life
you can have in New York it's it's very
much about the possibilities of being an
adult which means in a city like that
you were literally the second person
I've had a protracted conversation about
this show within the course of the last
six hours Cree summer who's a voice on
our masters the universe show was
talking about the show because I guess
she's Zoe's godmother or something she's
like the show is so good and then we
were talking and I was quizzing on the
same things so I that's the universe
telling me to watch it you should watch
it I'm in and it goes down so easy Hey
good to know I'm trying to think what
else I watched well I was I watched I
saw a [ __ ] movie man that like really
said oh I did I saw Invisible Man that
was well done you see it no cuz I'm a
wuss it's it's it's really well done I
thought it was very clever and then I
later on I found out they made it for
like 7 million I'm like what the [ __ ]
like it's incredible and then you sit
there gone you know what like an
Invisible Man movie is a cheap movie to
make you just missing somebody's old
ahmud cameo pretty much it's like just
shooting landscapes and [ __ ] but it was
insanely well done that cat was named
Lee why don't one Ally Whannell what a
well done man and you know it was really
dope to me I mean is it deep enough we
can talk about it I don't want to spoil
it but like honey you know you [ __ ]
the guy's invisible you know yeah we got
that do you know how he's invisible
know that I enjoyed immensely because it
is really like that's one of those
concepts it's like in a world of
believable movie sci-fi concepts
invisibility is real tough to get your
head
it's like what you came up with the
serum and now I can't [ __ ] see you
this makes no sense
somebody says I become a werewolf
because you know the moon I'm like oh I
buy that that makes sense but the idea
of [ __ ] that was always like come on
man
it's technology-based this time around
and it makes so much sense it's probably
like like technology based in the way
like this will never really happen but
it's just enough techno babble to make
you go like oh that [ __ ] you could
technically be invisible if one could
invent in the same way that when you
watch like Iron Man you like oh that's
science makes sense if you're in a
sci-fi universe instead of speaking of
which Oh have you seen all the [ __ ]
ink about [ __ ] dr. mage the sequence
and you know it I guess but I guess it's
Disney Plus so they're putting it on
that fat blu-ray boxset or something but
all this [ __ ] about stuff they cut out
of infinity war and end games yeah so
they showed like boards and they talked
about during the sequence where Doctor
Strange was being held captive by heaven
Emani sticking the needles in his face
and then Spiderman was like oh did you
ever see aliens or whatever [ __ ]
originally tony was going to send the
armor down to dr. strange in the way he
could in in Iron Man 3 and then the
armor covered him and turned him into
dr. mage and the instead of the you know
the arc reactor it built around the eye
of agamotto and then Tony was wearing
dr. strange cape and it brought him down
to him after however they dispatched
evany mall and there's footage or a
photo of Robert Downey jr. wearing the
Cape that was came out long before
infinity war came out as an early like
press release photo or something like
that so we know they shot it we know
personally that they shot it because
when the writers McFeely and Marcus
Marcus came and spoke to us at the house
before they went to do - big shindig and
[ __ ] for endgame before they left they
were like you want to
see something and they pulled out the
phone and literally showed us not just a
drawing because that's what's going
around the internet is there's a drawing
and [ __ ] looks badass and [ __ ] but they
showed us [ __ ] Sherlock in the Ironman
[ __ ] suit man like wearing the goddamn
suit with tony standing next to him
wearing the cape and we were like what
the [ __ ] in there like we can't they're
like we can't say no whatever we're
talking about it never tell anybody [ __ ]
and then it's out in the world and I'm
like oh my god we saw that [ __ ] photo
it looked badass man but like what they
did in the movie was totally cool to it
and it probably solved a lot of problems
more importantly but it looked [ __ ]
cool they built that [ __ ] suit and
what's-his-name was wearing it man Noah
Cumberbatch he was wearing that [ __ ]
City anyway we sidetracked severely I
saw a [ __ ] movie haunted me still
stays with me it's called swallow I
found it on iTunes holy [ __ ] man it's
about you know PI K is yes select dogs
will eat like dirt or [ __ ]
or like [ __ ] rocks and there's no
nutritional value people like want to
[ __ ] they do it no like spica as what
it's called human beings do it as well
apparently and there's some people that
just eat [ __ ] that has no nutritional
value because whatever they're dealing
with some [ __ ] they've got some issues
obviously or Twinkies yes yes baloney
not just that kind of nutritional value
like people that eat like in the movie
Jesus wife who's married to this exact
and he's kind of controlled by his
parents so he's seems kind of
controlling with her and [ __ ] they have
a pristine house and she's kind of
stay-at-home wife and and like she's
clearly bored out of her [ __ ] mind
and alone and by herself and then later
on the movie found out some backstory
stuff that helps it a lot make make a
lot more sense
so she finds like a marble like a kid's
marble and she swallows it and like she
seems so [ __ ] delighted by this and
then like couple scenes later she's in
the bathroom presumably [ __ ]
she puts on a glove I sue she put on the
glove I was like I'm in cuz I knew she
was gonna go digging further through her
shift through the marble I'm like this
movie's [ __ ] up man and she does pulls
on the rubber glove and she starts
digging and pulls out the marble has
some movie [ __ ] on it and then she
washed it off and she puts it on this
[ __ ] mirror and the way she put it on
I'm like and I ain't gonna be the only
one like I know they're gonna cut back
to that mirror and there's gonna be more
[ __ ] and god damnit they did because she
keeps eating [ __ ] the whole movie man
she eats a [ __ ] thumbtack oh no yes
she eats a safety pin at one point she
eats a battery at one point she eats a
screwdriver it's [ __ ] it's it's
batshit dude but apparently like there
are people that do this sort of thing
it's a real thing and she at one point
she's eating dirt like it was
fascinating as a character study not
just like dust [ __ ] up but it like the
performances were off the charts
wonderful I'd never seen this movie
before you know what I watched after
that did you ever see Midnight Special
yes wonderful movie Michael Shannon
Michael Shannon very original but at the
same time I've seen the movie before and
as much as like it reminds you of ET
like we're star man it's like this
[ __ ] might not be from here we
got to get them back where he's got to
go that story exists this [ __ ] story
where I'm like I swallow [ __ ] because
I'm alone holy [ __ ] man like I never saw
that before I was in 100% they couldn't
[ __ ] stop but it was one of those
movies to where everything she can't
beat and I'm like ah I'm like real
squeamish and [ __ ] like at one point
because I'm sitting there now like
moving like that you're trying to like
where the [ __ ] is this going you know
what I'm saying you watched most movies
yeah I got though you're gonna go here
here suddenly you're like how the [ __ ]
like it's only and it is one of those
movies you keep pressing the pause
because you're like how deep aren't we
and it's like 20 minutes you know like
there's like 90 more minutes than this
[ __ ] like where is it gonna go so early
on she gets exposed like [ __ ] because
she's like doubled over all the Rivera
yes like in like Al Capone's Balti opens
she's pregnant she's having a kid so one
point she's doubled over they bring into
the hospital oh no they're doing a
sonogram is even before she gets into
distress they're doing a sonogram on her
and [ __ ] and the lady during the
sonogram is like well there's the baby
there's the legs and she's like wait a
second there's something here and they
look down and they find like a bunch of
[ __ ] that we didn't see her eat in the
movie that has just been collecting in
her stomach because you can't digest it
and they [ __ ] make an incision and
they're with a scalpel bro they're
pulling out like a safety pin with like
[ __ ] hair on it [ __ ] it was [ __ ]
I'm telling you had captured my
imagination in such a big normally i
watch hit him on my phone at the same
time but this I was like no no no go on
what's namely well-done insanely well
done riveting [ __ ] picture man I have
no skin in the game but [ __ ] swallow
go check it out I swallowed it whole now
Kevin Smith I did not spit Kevin's pig
[Applause]
swallow you won't spit Kevin's the
perfect quote right there it's a
fantastic movie man I'm never gonna
watch it well you know what I'm watching
next is a movie you were singing its
praises fast color whoo it was between
midnight special and fast color and I
want Midnight Special but next up in my
queue is I'm watching you saying its
praises I'm doing a TV show to Amazon is
doing it I'm I cannot wait to talk about
fast color because much like into the
spider-verse
I could talk about fast color are you
doing that mark has been doing a series
that he kicked off one last night last
night was the first installment of the
Minority Report which is a film series
that I do at the let's go over at the
Alamo Drafthouse
where we're looking at genre films
through a somewhat diverse lens meaning
like diverse storytellers diverse
content diverse actors diverse points of
view and so the first movie were
serenity which joss whedon serenity not
the weird-ass
Matthew McConaughey oh yeah and you know
that you might say to yourself self
that's not the craziest diverse film
I've ever seen and you'd be right but
the thing that I want also wanted to
talk about in this
as much as there are movies that are all
about diversity and the second film and
the serious into the spider-verse
which is that but there's also the thing
that you have to do when you're a person
of color watching genre films especially
older genre films is kind of squint a
little bit at it and be like I don't
quite see myself in here or it's a
little bit problematic but I still love
it anyway my and it's it's finding your
way into something it's serenity if you
know anything about the Joss Whedon
firefigher world it's a world in which
China was the dominant cultural and an
economic force that eventually kind of
overtook America as the prime it was a
documentary about now very much so
but I'm so in the future China was the
dominant force so everybody speaks
Chinese everybody's names are kind of
Chinese there's Chinese writing
everywhere except that there are no
Asian actors on the show and it's like
if you're gonna make a show that's all
about that this is the world is that
intentional or no it's I'm not not for
the plot like the Asian person died they
know didn't have an Asian person there
are two characters whose last name is
Tam which is total Asian name and played
by white people
very good white people I love the cast
but it's just it's that weird blindspot
that that show has that if you're a fan
of it and a fan of color especially an
asian fan you've kind of got to just
swallow and move past if you're gonna
find your way to love it was subtle
reminder kids swallow night so yes first
one with serenity we sold out serenity
and you're doing it all year long oh
yeah every month once a month once a
month you put up the tickets today for
the second one which is into the spider
version tickets still available they are
not sold out that quick sold out in
hours Wow what are you gonna do 30 you
know announcing until the second one I'm
not going to announce yes I'm really
looking forward
that's our Edit point so for those who
missed tickets for both rounds now
they'll just have to pay attention where
do they go to the Alabama toss out on my
website
and I think the way to end up working is
that I'll announce the next film in the
series the day after we screen do the
previous one so and you're doing are you
doing a guest first by two verses I
would I think we're gonna get Peter
Ramsey the oscar-winning director oh
[ __ ] into the splatter for us to come
and talk
that's amazing which is [ __ ] awesome
great get great good for that show what
the [ __ ] about your home gel man like
I've been booking guests like a
[ __ ] I know you've been killing
it while I was away man like nothing but
love from the audience and [ __ ] like
that now it was so much fun but but it
was always like biding my time until my
husband got you're very sweet keep the
bed warm but at the same time like
building the the brand as well like I
was so proud of you when I saw that you
were doing the the series at the Alamo
Drafthouse that's you know this is a cat
who you know has never hesitated when I
was like hey let's do this it's like
okay but at the same time was never like
you know a lot of people in my life who
were like hey let's do this and I'm like
okay like I had to talk Marc in the [ __ ]
Marc wasn't like on get some [ __ ] done
through this guy here's all my [ __ ]
dreams instead I was like you know if I
can't talk about Batman and he was like
alright and from that from a guy who was
like a writer only and then an editor
for a while and and a guy like me who
dreamed of being in the business and
[ __ ] like that
watching you [ __ ] open up like a
flower over the last few years man where
it's like suddenly you're doing this
sudden they're doing this you're so
multifaceted at this point man it just
makes my heart soar man well done well
thank you I excellent job it is very
much in the model of like I I always
tell people what's like working with
Kevin he's the hardest-working dude I
know because there's always [ __ ]
something else is happening if there's
five things and it's all it's all
chasing bliss and sometimes swallowing
pills that you might not want to swallow
didn't get swallowing almost
it's haunting you now as well that's
what it is it's chasing blessed man like
if I can go for the thing that makes you
happy if you can make a little scratch
at the same time god bless but like
chiefly go for the thing that makes you
[ __ ] happy man and like the the
screening series like is clearly making
you happy and more importantly making
the audience [ __ ] happy for you to
sell out in [ __ ] hours after putting
up those tickets ourselves that's great
and it's not like heavy advertising it's
not like [ __ ] there's commercials and
[ __ ] if you literally putting one
[ __ ] Twitter Instagram footprint but
it's it's it's getting to talk about
things that I love and getting to talk
about why I love them and even if it's
problematic you know so much of being
alive in the world is finding ways to
love the things that that are that are
dinged on the outside the things we love
we don't look as they're perfect we love
them because of their flaws and be that
movies be a TV shows be good people like
ain't nothing perfect but you got to
find your way in and also you bring more
people into it too I mean I'm sure a lot
of people in the audience or like I love
this [ __ ] to that's why I'm here
but you always have a chance to reach
somebody news like I never [ __ ] seen
serenity you know I'll give it a shot
now and stuff and it's so important to
grow fans new fans particularly like you
know catch people who haven't been with
you from the jump we're with a thing
from the [ __ ] jump that's how a thing
keeps living i I got you know I've been
out on the road for four months and
stuff so I've seen the fan base and a
lot of them look like me and as much as
their middle age and they've been with
me since like [ __ ] the 90s when I
started with clerks but then there's
like waves of like oh my god are those
twenty year olds and like oh my god did
somebody bring a [ __ ] teenager and
and and you know you're so like
disturbed by it at first we were like
[ __ ] who would bring like why are you
here first a teenage you're like why the
[ __ ] are you even here like how would
you even understand all these old
references and [ __ ] like that and
they're like well my parents used to
watch the movie with my parents like I
can they would get together we'd watch
them they were
our thing and then you're like who what
[ __ ] irresponsible parent would show
you these movies and that irresponsible
parent would stand up and be like me and
they were there with the person man it's
important like well it important to my
bottom line of course to pass on fandom
to somebody else but it's just important
to pass on fandom in general to go out
there and advocate for the [ __ ] you like
even if like people aren't talking about
that [ __ ] thing anymore man like you
know while we're here we might as well
speak about the man on your [ __ ]
shirt Max von Sydow
the late great max a late great black
pants we go
when you know I saw that he passed and
sadly passed how old 90 90 90 90 years
old huge bucket of win as we say on
Hollywood babble-on
tickets for that going on sale very soon
well done it I looked at his entire
career we talked about very briefly back
in the alley way before we jumped in our
green room like yeah he was one of the
most respected actors in the [ __ ]
world and then he had they worked with
Bergman [ __ ] Seventh Seal and we all
know him as man who literally [ __ ]
played chess with death he's a man if
he's the [ __ ] living metaphor as an
actor and [ __ ] like that so he said
classy classy ass [ __ ] roles but he
also did a [ __ ] ton of genre yes so and
that put him squarely in our world so
it's one thing when you lose like a
great actor chip is another thing when
you're like we lost Ming the [ __ ]
merciless man we lost brewmeister Smith
man we lost [ __ ] the dude from dune
Hooda plan to you know kind yes we lost
Jesus he played Christ once and yeah and
the devil was wow man that's right and
needful things he was the devil was well
he was a dude who follow his bliss and
if his bliss took him to [ __ ] judge
dredd all right I'll do Judge Dredd if
he takes him to Conan I'll do Conan I'll
be king Osric sure and he [ __ ]
elevated everything never once did he do
something where you're like uh max
fancied out [ __ ] it blue like whatever
he did even if you didn't like the movie
like Judge Dredd you know if I can
Mohammed he's armed
I'm not and he doesn't have his helmet
on you're like what the [ __ ] but max was
like [ __ ] so damn strong in a movie
in many times throughout his entire
career so damn strong and earnest in a
movie that probably didn't deserve it or
where nobody else was given it as much
so classy that he treated like a list
material clearly great material the same
that he would treat material that other
people would just kind of throw away I
what an astounding career but you're
absolutely right he followed his [ __ ]
bliss man yeah I mean and there's the
high end there's a low there's that for
every three days of the Condor
you know there's [ __ ] never say never
again which he was still good at man
he's always a Blofeld like he every time
and maybe it's the the accent the
delivery the voice or maybe he was just
that [ __ ] good like maybe it's like
you're so used to seeing movie stars and
[ __ ] that when you see someone who is a
full utility all-around performer actor
man that can like do anything it's
astounding you're like wow he's one off
but shouldn't all shouldn't they all be
like that like I wish I was that [ __ ]
talented man what a crazy wonderful
career how many people did that guy make
happy yeah I mean even playing the bad
guy and like getting to like live in
[ __ ] Conan and Star Wars and Game of
Thrones and minions and young Indiana
Jones like he's found his way into
almost every sort of franchise every
family every legacy thing that we loved
and wasn't snobby about it no oh yeah
let me show up and do this happy - yeah
give me my quote I'll be there and I'll
be good at it I read something online
recently we're like somebody mentioned
strange brew to him and he played
brewmeister Smith and he was [ __ ]
amazing
but somebody mentioned to him and he
instantly broke into a wide smile and he
was like I forgot about that one and he
suddenly was warmed you know like even
that like the fact that he shows up let
alone shows up to a strange brew let
alone gives like an incredibly funny and
earnest performance that anytime plays
against type and uses his ability to
if I can make the character more arch uh
he'll be missed man I mean I was an
actor who like a lot of actors that when
they pass them like man I wish I'd
worked with that cat I never wish I
worked with them because I always felt
like he was way out of my [ __ ] league
like who would he play [ __ ] Silent
Bob's grandpa like there's nothing I
would never do anything and maybe with
red state like I might have got close
like he could have been like you know if
there was no Michael parks like a great
pastor Aven Cooper and stuff but he he
was he was too good for me to even dream
about like what would it be like to work
with him and stuff
I envy JJ JJ got to work with them right
like I'm on force awakens and it was a
strong way to begin the movie man like
oh my god they got [ __ ] you're like
holy [ __ ] they got Max von Sydow
then [ __ ] like holy [ __ ] they just
killed max mamacita they're like we got
so much money we're gonna kill everybody
dude you love who will save a few for
the rise of Scott Walker but yes r.i.p
max one seed oh yeah big time all right
we gather to talk about news should we
dive into this do some news Mark's got
news everybody give it up for Mark Minar
and he's got some news for you take us
to that juicy newsy place new Z before
we get too deep into it your thoughts on
the Batmobile since we first sat down we
got a good look at both of the Batman
and the Batmobile I'm gonna pronounce it
wrong a lot how's your feeling on the
the hash tag family Fast and the Furious
yeah there was a bat in the Furious I
think it it's cool it looks like it
reminds me of the Bears Batmobile a
little bit like in as much as they they
took a normal car and retrofitted it I
I'm not taking anything away from Nolan
he never wants to anything anti Nolan
because [ __ ] they'll come and kill you
and [ __ ] but I mean the tumbler was not
I was like I get it but it was a tank
yeah and so and but to be fair like I
thought you know Zach's
that will be it was like well that looks
complicated
I I but at the same time my favorite
Batmobile of all time is Tim Burton's
Batmobile which is also an overly
complicated and [ __ ] vehicle and
stuff but that's I love that Batmobile
but this I was like I didn't I didn't
shake it didn't chafe at all I wasn't
like what the [ __ ] if they're doing a
year 1 year 2 story this all makes sense
that like he doesn't have the [ __ ]
brand new goddamn expensive supercar and
[ __ ] I it looks like they're doing
progression on the costume so like by
the end of the movie we'll probably see
something that's a little more uniform
but it feels like he's piecing it
together and seeing what works and she
don't like that in the storyline I guess
that would be my conjecture based on the
very limited stuff we've seen so far but
I like it man that helmet reminds me
very much of an Elseworlds Batman story
where he played it wasn't the pirate one
maybe it was the Gotham by Gaslight it
very looked much looks like Gotham by
Gaslight to me that the hell yeah yeah a
little bit but I'm in man like
forgetting he's it's the one thing that
I was like aw man I wish that hadn't got
out was they showed footage him on a
bat-cycle yeah and it looked pretty dope
and then also he dumps right I can't and
I'm like nobody needs to see Batman on a
motorcycle but it looks it looks cool
man I'm in I think he's doing the right
things but let's talk about the big
[ __ ] news right the rumor of the week
there's a big rumor going around that
says they've been talking to Johnny Depp
about possibly playing the Joker in his
the bat in Matt Reeves the Batman movie
now this is the first anyone's even
heard about there being a possibility of
a joker in the Batman movie on the heels
of the Joker which won Oscars and made
over a billion dollars and Joaquin just
locked that part down but it looks like
you know now this is Oscar bait partner
who the [ __ ] wouldn't want to play the
Joker
like what Heath Ledger won an Oscar
Joaquin Phoenix won an Oscar and of all
me actors out there that they could
possibly like take a roll the dice on
the Joker Johnny Depp actually kind of
[ __ ]
perfect that's a rumor that's going
around is I don't know where it came
from but there's been some conjecture
online yeah like I read it in the India
Times which doesn't fill me with a ton
of confidence not that India can't have
a good news yeah what the [ __ ] mark
you're saying like if that's the first
place that I see it it's a little weird
you gotta trace the source back yeah
what would you think personally I kind
of want to give the Joker a bit of a
rest like yeah but in the world well
that's not gonna happen what do you
think like they're never gonna that's
like like let's get Batman or us like
[ __ ] you he makes a billion dollars all
the time let's imagine that like if it's
one scene yes one scene he's not the
whole movie one scene toward the end
they're like [ __ ] we want to have the
Joker and [ __ ] and it's gonna be Johnny
Depp what do you say to that I only want
it to happen if he's painted his makeup
over a mustache if it's legit cesar
romero like just oh my gosh it's looking
mustache but I'm also kind of crazy
stache you you say it in a humorous way
but Johnny Depp so odd he might just
[ __ ] do that man he might be like the
whole thing's an homage just he's a
Romero's oh I painted over yeah he would
be you got to admit he'd be fun man like
that like of all the parts he's played
he's kind of like perfect for a take on
the Joker I'll be interesting to say the
least and if it's in a very small dose
because there's 98 other villains in
that movie already well they've got a
Riddler they've got a Catwoman who
technically might not be a villain
they've got a penguin penguin do they
have a Harvey Dent no sounds like they
are doing long Halloween doesn't mean he
does have a Falcone and maybe they're
not done casting maybe that's just all
we've heard about yeah like for example
they announced our masters in the
universe cast and I know there are a lot
more people that aren't announced that
are [ __ ] cool too
whoo I'll tell you later on I recorded
some of them today it was pretty amazing
am I in it yeah Jason Mewes has been
announced yeah he already recorded his
stink or lines
well done such typecasting he was
wonderful all right so wait man I made
up for that I'm in so far they have not
lost me but to be fair we host a show
called fat man beyond that was called
fat man I'm Batman like I'm in for every
iteration of Batman this one actually
has me excited yes I can't wait I
understand I saw some people on Twitter
being like [ __ ] on the helmet but
I'm like I buy it some people said the
two the points were too high listen we
endured a dude who couldn't like this
was his holiness you want to tell the
kids like our Batman back in honor day
he couldn't even [ __ ] if he wanted to
fight somebody be like where are you
yeah there's all that data by me
thank God man the moment imagine like
the [ __ ] jump the whole thing took
when Chris Nolan like did that scene
where he's just like you want to be able
to turn your head like the whole
audience after 20 years been like yeah
look at scale that [ __ ] wears armor for
mobility it really worked but Zach took
it back to like it was all part of the
bodysuit yeah and the cape and stuff so
this looks like separation again looks
like he could turn his head right you
[ __ ] ninja ninja with like 40 degree
vision like with nothing peripheral BAM
hold on but that's how good he is even
with 40 degree vision he could still
kick everybody's ass is that you Killer
Croc now wait stop it step in front of
me so we could fight all right what do
you got there my mirrors up hold on
guardians of the galaxy characters are
gonna be in [ __ ] thora love and
thunder says who says Vin Diesel who
apparently said way more on the press
tour for bloodshot than he should have
cuz that's the way you get news out of
[ __ ] is you get him a little
tired at the end of a day it's like hey
man what's next for you he said like
James Gunn's talking about going back
for guardians if James Gunn you know
taking Suicide Squad so he's about to
embark on vol 3 he also talked to me
about how Thor will incorporate some of
the guardians of galaxies which will be
very interesting
nobody knows maybe I shouldn't have said
anything literally that's his quote he
just gave the way the farm man he's
really [ __ ] dead Wow me granted you
know and maybe he was the leak about
Johnny Depp in the Batman as well what
else you want to know I mean they did
tease it you know at the very end of
endgame of the as guardians of the
galaxy it's good to know as Abaddon good
you know that it's happening also good
to know he can say a lot more than I am
Groot he can't when he wants to
and apparently when nobody else wants
him to yeah and it's all about family
when's that other movie coming out
bloodshot not a car movie oh fast nine I
think May I want to say either end of
May or early June and blood shot yeah
based on a comic book for the valiant
universe it is a valuable isn't it
uh-huh
when's that coming out like three weeks
Oh should we be talking about it this
week um for Friday
do you know anything about other than
the fact that on the [ __ ] press about
shitty so much everything go I mean I
know generally what the concept is is
that he's basically this Universal
Soldier right like he was a soldier who
thanks to some nanite injection can kind
of never be killed again brought back
from the Gabe gets superpowers and now
wants to know who's done this to him and
why and then he'll blow a ton of shut up
and yeah I live my life a quarter mile
at a time I am Superman
that's coming out in the next three
weeks and then the fast nine past nine
happens this summer yeah so he's got a
big year he's nothing
and then apparently next year will bring
a Thor movie that Groot may or may not
be in I mean like is he even like do you
think they even bring it on the set for
guardians of the galaxy no no I'm saying
like like I'm not taking anything away
from him because I love what he does as
group but like on set any kid but
anybody could just be like I am Groot
like and move on I mean James Gunn did
most of the dancing so it's not even
like Vin Diesel doing it yeah exactly I
mean she had Bradley Cooper I don't even
think he goes to set does he he does no
because Sean Gunn plays rocket rocket
and he also does the voice so then
Bradley Cooper dubs it later so he's
never on set either
Bradley Cooper and Vin Diesel are two of
the [ __ ] luckiest actors on the
planet because they're in a massive
franchise now they're about to be in a
second massive franchise and [ __ ] and
they don't even have to show up for work
for that [ __ ] job just one day in
front of a microphone they're also in
the most precarious position because
they [ __ ] we get somebody sounds
just like you yeah but like like not
every you know woody is actually Tom
Hanks he's got a brother who needs some
work and so every time Woody's on a TV
show that's like his brother Phil Hanks
I'm sure there's some music ain't nobody
like me but me there's a dozen [ __ ]
guys that have but they do that because
Tom Hanks is like I'm too busy they
don't use his brother Jim Hanks be like
we're gonna keep you in line Tom Hanks
because if you don't do what we say
Jim Hanks is right the [ __ ] here he'll
do it for 10 percent of what you can
[ __ ] see he is though Jim Hanks is
the go-to guy for the pull toys and some
of the TV shows and the interstitials
and stuff but it's like you know if all
you are as a voice actor and your voice
isn't necessarily crazy unreplicated a
replicable no that's a weird yeah you
may not be an [ __ ] about it listen
man we're happy to pay you this money
but if you're
[ __ ] I can swing a dead cat hit
somebody can sound like rocket and you
could go from I am Groot to I am out of
a [ __ ] job pretty quick
alright so that's good to know yeah yeah
and also I can't wait for that when's
that happening what's the release date
and which is gonna happen first Thor
love and thunder or this guardians the
galaxy movie though our love and thunder
because that's November 20 21 and
Christian Bale's your bad guy he's
playing a bad guy
what's tested Thompson revealed that she
wasn't supposed to again on a press tour
for a West world do you think if you're
Kevin Feige like shut the [ __ ] up
you can't ever do any other job oh my
god would you just say the words on the
page mock all these people always
spelling a good newsman I heard another
piece of good [ __ ] news
did you hear that spider-man the new
spider-man movie gonna have a lawyer in
it a lawyer yes a famous Marvel Universe
lawyer is it is it is it the she-hulk
another famous Charlie Cox they're
bringing in as Matt Murdock that's been
the rumor online and they say that's
like the one that like Marvel's like god
damn it how did that get out if they do
that [ __ ] chefs kiss man because now
the rumor beyond that rumor is that once
they introduce them in spider-man
daredevil getting in his own movie with
Charlie Cox playing them same [ __ ]
cats
that would be so smart oh my god who
didn't love that [ __ ] daredevil and
to give him a chance at the big screen
and [ __ ] and like you know look they're
opening up the Marvel [ __ ] toy chest
right now you know it's not gonna be the
same six [ __ ] all the time it's like
now we're doing this now we're trying
this use your blind lawyer yeah I know
what a movie called the same six [ __ ]
look they're back the same so yeah
they're there open it the [ __ ] up man so
it sounds like daredevil gonna get his
own movie again and I think that the
super exciting thing about that is you
did daredevil them the cages viable and
then the Punisher is vile yes and the
Punisher the spider-man is a legit
[ __ ] thing did you do you can't do
that though it would have to be a PG
Punisher or an r-rated spider-man pg-13
is I just put that difference speak in a
spider-man can't protect a written blue
yes they just hired Robert and he says
nay or C or C to write a spider-man
universe spin-off Sony just hired
they're not saying what it is what do
you think it is let's speculate let's
speculate you speculate first because
I'm going to steal your speculation I
feel I'll [ __ ] say you're reading I
am I'm reading this is from Tom Curley
once my science book but he says Kevin
I'm no Scott Mosier but I did win an
Oscar for mixing whiplash is that
[ __ ] true oh [ __ ]
you got an Oscar we got an Oscar winner
an ass man
[Applause]
whiplashed the [ __ ] drum movie where
he smacks the kid a couple thousand
times [ __ ] movies excellent so what
did you do so you mixed every one of
those [ __ ] slaps oh yeah
that's awesome what number one what a
wonderful movie number two were those
did you have to augment him or were
those like his real slide really hit him
team really I mean it you know not super
hard but but enough for you to hear it
yeah and then you just dial that [ __ ] up
put a little reverb on it so did you go
up on stage oh yeah Captain America
handed me my Oscar go stand in the
spotlight man so Chris Evans presented
yep no just for that or dia for that for
the he presented for that award yeah so
you got up and he handed you a [ __ ]
Oscar totally what did you get to say in
the time I thank my crew I was trying
not to pass up fair I mean why because
you were surprised shot who will you up
against interstellar American sniper
oh my god yeah whose dick did you suck
to win that award no wonder you were
trying not to pass it that's stiff
competition what else was that I there
was two others and blanking I'm sorry
but those two alone because I know the
way Oscar voters [ __ ] vote yeah they
just go I've heard of this movie and
they if I could go for that and an
interstellar they're like oh that's
expensive and they vote for that and
[ __ ] they actually had to really [ __ ]
think in order to go like you know what
man the [ __ ] sound design they move
and that is a movie that's all about
music and drum music Ron Geoff [ __ ] a
yeah
what is uh what's his name Damian was he
like oh he's great good against probably
the most well prepared director I've
ever worked for its what is the other
ones who are the least of merit
directors
because we need him as a sound mixer we
actually had meetings like really yeah
he'd want to talk about like what's
going is like how to do it what's gonna
work best you know he considered it an
actual tool in the storytelling box you
know so when you get the award did you
you must have [ __ ] thanked him right
well we collectively did and then I well
they tell us when we get nominated that
only one person is allowed to speak
which totally doesn't happen but I just
didn't want to be the guy that got play
it off so I was like trying to play it
safe and then I got three seconds at the
end and I thank my crew [ __ ] a man
that what is it what was it like like
after that when you went back to do you
have to stain you very much to the night
or do you go well it's a whirlwind I
mean they brought us back to there's
like a camera where you say stuff to eat
for God and then they whiskey it I like
you know there's like the Foreign Press
and then the video press and then the
radio press and then like you're walking
around all kinds of hallways and like
hyperventilating and rock walks by and
you know and
all of a sudden I had like a glass of
champagne and and then like they don't
let you go back to your seat until
there's a commercial break they have a
seat fillers so I had to like stand off
in the wings for you know a couple
minutes till a commercial break happen
and then they shove you back it was the
coolest person who congratulated you
when you were backstage because you're
holding a [ __ ] awesome yeah right
well miles teller was back there he was
getting ready for a little bit that they
were doing and so you know we did jumped
around and do you walk away with the
statue yeah does everybody on the crew
gets a statue yeah and it is it's a
you're [ __ ] on it or is that completely
afterwards they put the the Governor's
Ball they have like a plaque thing where
they make them so you go to the
Governor's Ball with your Oscar and
you're like can't get my name please and
they put it on the [ __ ] statue yeah
so you have to go to the [ __ ]
Governor's Ball you do and if you win
only yeah that's why I don't want to win
an Oscar who wants to go to that [ __ ]
party that's amazing man what was who
did you talk to first like not in the
room who's the first person you called
ah my father because I I was there with
my mother oh my god man that is
beautiful how [ __ ] proud was she thank
God I was gonna open with like you
must've got so late after you won that
award that night I had to get rid of her
for yeah yeah that [ __ ] rocks man so
what year was that that's going back to
those 2015 do you get to up your price
after that oh yeah well it makes it
gettinghired a lot easier to that's
right right cuz you like oh by the way
yeah put it on the desk yeah [ __ ]
rocks man I'm so glad I open the book
man give it up for Tom thank you done
Wow man [ __ ] it's awesome is that you
never get deer [ __ ] like that
alright where were we poor Tom [ __ ]
rudely a go tom
speaking of she-hulk mark ruffalo is in
talks to appear in the she-hulk TV show
I've read that today how exciting is
that
this [ __ ] Marvel Universe TV [ __ ]
they're doing a Disney Plus it just
sounds fantastic it sounds like a dream
[ __ ] come true they're literally just
making longer movies and cutting them up
into chapters yes and spending all of
the money on them to get [ __ ] Ruffalo
to show up for like a bit part as Bruce
Banner to give a blood injection to his
cousin that's crazy
we live in that world now we live in
that world but that's [ __ ] awesome I
love the idea of it and I love that
people are still involved I also saw an
article where they're talking about
Robert Downey jr. is talking about like
hey I want to do something but like hey
you're pretty expensive
yeah but he's like hey but did you see
Doolittle and then like knows like
nobody did hey can I do something oh you
think it's in relation to that I mean it
doesn't hurt that he just had a massive
global failure how massive I don't have
the precise numbers but I think they
spent somewhere upwards of about 200
million dollars making that movie and
and did not do well I can be honest with
you though man if I'm in charge of the
studio who made that Universal yeah I'm
a charged Universal and they're like you
want to make a 200 million [ __ ]
Robert Downey jr. talks to animals
movies I'd be like oh my gun and [ __ ]
done
like I would have bet on that I can't
even say like that's stupid they've made
that movie a bunch and with him you just
imagine like it was gonna kill so that's
oddly I mean I wouldn't have seen that
coming I would have bet the farm on that
movie that being said I didn't see it so
I'm part of the problem yes literally
Universal did bet a farm on it full of
animals nobody would swallow that Taika
Waititi oh he's so creative
he's so and busy
than [ __ ] yeah he is making - you got an
Oscar now - they did before the masker
yeah you wanted [ __ ] yeah
he's making - cartoons for Netflix both
of which are coming out of the Willy
Wonka universe oh really
yeah he's made he's doing doll stuff
he's doing yeah he's doing a legit like
just Charlie in the Chocolate Factory
and then a separate Oompa Loompa movie
and they're animated yeah like sorry
series you doing - series don't know the
style of the animation yet I mean but
yeah he's working with the Roald Dahl
story company which is the estate and
yeah like if anybody if I want to see
anybody make that kind of movie I want
to see him do that I saw a tweet read
before I came here today they said if
they're really looking to cast like Reed
Richards as a guy who like has a million
ideas at one time they're like they
should look no further than this and it
was a picture of Tyco YTD and I was like
oh my god I could totally [ __ ] work
yeah that's the dude who misses dinner
because he's inventing in the lab yeah
so I'm in for that man what else you go
there's a there seems to be a tidal wave
of delays and rescheduling and
cancellations because of the corona
virus yeah and the James Bond movie that
was supposed to open in like three weeks
it's not pushing to Thanksgiving yeah
well he just did the episode last week's
episode of SNL but and I imagine that
was in a motion of James Bond but
there's no James Bond to promote you
know they said they're gonna lose like
30 million move in the movie I mean
because they spend a [ __ ] ton
marketing it now and they have to market
it again and do a member right and all
that money is gone but it's just the
beginning of what is maybe going to me
for the next few months until
everybody's a handle on it [ __ ] going
away that we were looking forward to
South by Southwest has canceled
Coachella is pushing to October I think
right WonderCon is in a month
like what happens to that when I was a
Comic Con in July yeah Emerald City
Comicon cancelled that was that made me
think that once that happened South by
Southwest wasn't far behind but at least
the Emerald City Comicon made a lot of
sense because there's cases in Seattle
the Austin one that was the City of
Austin going we're calling it right now
yeah you know and there's there's a very
good chance that they canceled the
Olympics what do you think happens to
how deep does this go like does Comic
Con still happen it's final question I
mean because you want to talk about
putting a bunch of [ __ ] people in a
tight space sweaty bodies coffin [ __ ]
touch and rub that's an event can Film
Festival as well yeah it's coming up
they got to make some decision soon
you know and then the sporting events
where there are balls or pucks throwing
around like you're about to get into the
Final Four you're about to get into
football season you're about to get into
the things that America seems to do a
lot which is gather a bunch of people in
spaces that are somewhat confined with
bad circulation
it's so weird I'm so myopic I forgot
like oh my god sports like there's a
bunch of people get together and like
watch sport like football games they
have like tens of thousands of people
yeah I mean college football you know
like eighty ninety thousand people in
stands and the Olympics it's a billion
dollar investment in Japan and not to
say that the dollar sign is the only
thing that's interesting or noteworthy
about it but Japan is the only other
place the only other time in Olympics
has been canceled was also in Japan for
what World War two yeah you would
brought the room down we're like oh
sorry game oh that happened 1940 alright
so are you glad you're off to her I mean
I am glad that we're affinity we've
finished the tour because it would have
been much harder to sell tickets in a
world where people like I don't want to
get
but I feel bad for like we had a movie
at South by Southwest my friend Malcolm
Ingram directed a movie about me a
documentary called Klerk and I was kind
of looking forward to it
you know CNN stuff but I'll see it
someplace else a bunch of filmmakers and
Malcolm's been to that festival before
and he's made a bunch of movies a bunch
of first-time filmmakers that were like
we got into South but I thought this is
the beginning and [ __ ] and now it's just
done and it's not like oh we're doing it
three months later they're just not
doing it so 2020 doesn't happen and so
all those people and that's just the
film side but then you got bands that
we're coming out there and built a whole
tour around kicking off at South by and
moving on so it's it's I mean it makes
sense what they did but it's you know
kind of heartbreaking like all the way
down never mind the people who had their
hopes pinned to the event then there are
people who live off the events like all
the service industry folks and stuff
like that bunch of restaurants in Austin
probably sitting on a [ __ ] ton of
product that they thought that they were
gonna be moving and now they're they're
not moving it so if you're in the Austin
area go out to eat man I'm surprised
that like Netflix hasn't stepped in and
says you know what we're gonna do a
virtual south-by-southwest like every
movie that was supposed to screen we
will scream indieWIRE announced that
they're gonna review all the movies
regardless yeah I thought that was nice
but like let people see them and maybe
find a way to charge extra so that the
people who were out money at that of the
actual festival can somehow get a piece
of that back mmm but it seems as if
that's a thing you can solve if
Coachella can broadcast the entirety of
a weekend online and you can watch
Beyonce slay then why can't you actually
do the same thing with a Film Festival
find ways to do the Q&A afterwards and
have the moby virtue on have you even
have a crowd you know Q&A session
[ __ ] get McEwan it's like [ __ ]
twitch but for a festival the only
problem then those if you've got a film
that you're selling at a festival and
stuff and you just put it out online you
don't have a film to sell anymore the
internet owns it once it's digital it's
out of your hands like a performance at
Coachella they'll go perform that song a
couple thousand times
bunch of different places and stuff but
the movie you're like all we have is the
movie if we give the movie away we're
[ __ ] that's the only reason why they
wouldn't do
I would imagine think about it because
no festival I mean generally they have
some movies like you know kind of
retrospective screenings but 95 98
percent of your movies or here's [ __ ]
you've never seen and if you've never
seen the [ __ ] before and they're just
debuting it online anybody the computer
now has that [ __ ] and you don't have any
more [ __ ] to sell yeah I mean but there
are also like I was a previous member of
the press you get screening links for
[ __ ] all the time
yeah and that's how those [ __ ] movies
get out Jay and Silent Bob reboot
[ __ ] got out through a review link
yeah from Universal we kept very tight
on the American side Universal had it
internationally they gave out a link for
screening and it was suddenly online and
stuff so yeah once it's digital give it
up it's like telling somebody a secret
once you do it assume everyone's gonna
[ __ ] know so I like your vision but
it goes against common sense you know
that's a hard pill to swallow
it's very hopeful what else you got uh
they are again the Disney Plus making a
Beauty and the Beast prequel series is
this the one everyone was mad about two
months ago
oh no it's Aladdin remember Aladdin
they're gonna do a spin-off show with
the one one guy in the land and it was
like that's a bad [ __ ] look whoops
wait this ain't that
this is Gaston and Lefou are getting
their own show Josh GAD was Lefou and
Luke Evans was Gaston oh and they're
getting their own show again oh [ __ ]
Josh GAD is showing it I believe he's
show running it yeah are they a couple
they should be a couple because that's a
hot show right there freezing gay for
each other I know right if that's the
show they got a hit on their hands [ __ ]
yes
Wow so there they are spending all the
[ __ ] money so much money you know
what we all win like some cool shit's
gonna happen because of it I mean I'm
not in for that show but they don't do
another [ __ ] that they're gonna have me
for you watch the Chernobyl show right I
did not you didn't watch what in
Chernobyl I watched the first episode
and it was pretty depressing and then I
stopped you
but that's how it works though yeah so
depressing makes you feel better about
your own life it's like a blues song
didn't have that effect on me I
understand it want awards and people
loving stuff but I'm I'm a Sunnyside a
street kind of guy okay tune in to
swallow you guys I like my [ __ ] where
people eat fucked-up [ __ ]
not because like nuclear radiation tells
them to because they're bored housewives
it's just the most I have not why I did
watch the first episode and then I
didn't watch the rest the guy who who
created it and wrote every episode of it
Craig Mazin is an avowed video game fan
Am I and his next project after winning
like nine Emmys for Chernobyl is an
adaptation of the game Last of Us which
is I don't know I just made a face like
oh oh I don't know what the [ __ ] that is
the video game dude again I was just
stuck on Craig Mazin want a bunch of
Emmys yeah for that chair noble thing
uh-huh Craig Mazin also he did one of
the scary movies you did I think like
scary movie night a bunch of thing did
he really he wrote like that's inspiring
two and three well I mean but those made
[ __ ] money it did he was he also made
that he was he was a Bob Weinstein kid
he did that a superhero movie he liked
the spoof movie with Raj whatever it was
called it might have been superheroes
was a superhero movie he wrote chair
noble and then won a bunch of Emmys yeah
that ought to [ __ ] teach everybody
out there like it don't matter what you
do one day you could be doing the
[ __ ] superhero spoof movie and the
next day be winning Emmys and then doing
a video game show I've never heard of
what is the property The Last of Us this
game came out at seven years ago and
it's gorgeous
it is one of my favorite games over not
because the gameplay is amazing or
whatever what is the plot the plot is
zombie apocalypse oh that's original and
and there's a young woman she's like 13
14 years old who happens to be immune to
this
virus and so she has to be ferried from
one side of whatever to the other side
of wherever and in order to do that
there's this guy named Joel who turns
out to be her sort of guardian angel
slash you know bodyguard slash surrogate
father figure and it's all about the
relationship these two people who hated
each other at the beginning of the game
develop and bond and fuse by the end of
the sounds like a TV show very much so
but it is one of the very few games I've
ever played
where by the end of it I cried because
the the what happens over the course of
this game the the evolution of their
relationship the events that challenge
that relationship and and push them to
the edge of reality and and heart and
health and all that [ __ ] it's
devastating by the time it ends in a way
that's wonderful and have never felt
that way in a game and then played it
again just to feel that thing again and
how long does it take to play twenty
five thirty hours I think and you've
done it twice then twice will you watch
the show because you've lived it
absolutely wow that's high praise it's
very good and so very exciting that it's
gonna be on HBO they're investing in it
the way they invested in Watchmen the
way invest in West world which is a big
[ __ ] show spending money spending
money and it's got a kid lead yeah I
mean basically it's a lone wolf cubby
kind of thing we gotta get these a
little older than sorry Lomo cubby it's
a good Mandalorian kind of thing we got
to get this kid from here to here yeah
she is not nearly as cute as the baby
will they haven't cast yet you don't
know don't know she's not gonna have
those eyes that's that's a show worth
looking out for you're saying oh yeah
it's super early development it could
take years and years but the fact that
it's coming makes me very happy
fuckin'-a my friends all the news we
have that's all the news it's all the
news that last things max wants to know
give it up for mark he brought you the
news
[Applause]
we haven't done all the news I think
there's one last story to do mark have
you seen the pictures of Kumail holy
[ __ ]
I want a [ __ ] who mailman like oh my god
he is so Kumail got in shape for the
Eternals yeah and since he was [ __ ]
in gorgeous shape Men's Journal did a
photo shoot with him where he reenacted
famous movie scenes where dudes were
shirtless and [ __ ] and he played
Wolverine and looked incredibly [ __ ]
convincing
he played Patrick Bateman from American
Psycho skipping-rope
he played was a Top Gun it was well John
McClane John McClane the elevator chef
and I think and one of them was a
bigamist Top Gun Rachel anthologies
playing volleyball my god he like he
looks incredible in he looks like an
action figure I mean if I got into that
shape it's never gonna happen but if I
did I would take all the pictures also I
mean it was a smart [ __ ] thing to do
and he's been like talking about how he
lost the weighted [ __ ] like I read one
headline was like he didn't eat brownies
for a year and I was like [ __ ] that I
couldn't do that
but if Marvel's paying enough and like
[ __ ] like giving you the high tech
trainer and [ __ ] like why not use a job
like he'd crisp ratted himself yeah like
that's crazy man like it might go from
like oh we all know who Camille is to
like we had no idea and he may be like
the next Chris Pratt like getting
[ __ ] leading man roles I'm sure and
not leading man roles cuz like oh he's
funny leading my roles cuz like take
your [ __ ] shirt off you're sexy now
alright so we did all the news now that
we've done Camille that's all the news
now we get to the part of the show
ladies and gentlemen where we do Q&A we
open the Q&A questions up to the
audience and then share with you
fabulous [ __ ] prizes man
and this week we've got - oh that - yeah
and okay all right so yeah yeah because
we've already got that we got there but
let's make it a comeback show you want
sweeten the pot it's [ __ ] oh yeah
fair enough so what we've got is four
then if I'm correct prizes unless you
want to hold this till next week I guess
well we had two tickets and then all the
wait two tickets one set of two all
right so now we got three things
giveaway sorry kids basic math we're
getting there we have three things to
give away one we have a set of tickets
our good friend Brett Deacon gave us
tickets - two tickets to 40x is that
correct a 40x screening I've been
singing the praises of 40x for a long
time kids the easiest way for me to say
it is it's like going to a movie that's
also a roller coaster that just comes
this shy of blowing you that's how I
like satisfying the whole 4dx experience
is you've seen a 40 X movies I have
indeed I've seen a 40 X Mark you barely
swallow it's crazy it's definitely worth
checking out a big expensive movie you
wanted to check out something like Jay
and Silent Bob rebooting 40 X because
who knows what they throw in your face
but a Marvel movie hell yeah that's what
you want a slack Widow which is coming
up black widow man speaking of which we
even talked about that what do you think
of the new trailer the new trailers
their first relevant really made me want
to see black some of that taskmaster
that's a past master that's yeah that
really brought me in was just like oh
that's tight and then there's a photo
but they've been putting online I guess
there's a trailer shot of him watching
the overhead camera shot from Iron Man 2
when they introduced Black Widow and she
breaks into Hammer Corp and just starts
[ __ ] kicking ass they show him
watching that and I was like oh that's a
good call back I look forward to that
okay so we've got a set of 40 X tickets
we also have right here this gorgeous
why are we given this away I'll take
this
Batman the definitive history of the
Dark Knight in comics film and Beyond
published by the good folks at insight
editions man this book as thick as a
dick and will kill somebody it's perfect
for the bathroom a lifetime it would
take you to get through this perfect for
a coffee table it's a classy [ __ ]
prize and then another third of our
three prizes Marc brought in here tell
them what it is yeah that is a download
code for final draft 11 if you are an
aspiring screenwriter this is the this
is the Bible this is the tool this is
your rosetta stone this is also crazy
[ __ ] expensive and I'm not saying it
just because it is but it is and it's
it's like the barrier for entry if you
want to be professional screenwriter
every TV show every movie gets written
in this program or at some point gets
converted into this program because it
is how the industry runs the journey of
a million mile miles begins with final
draft and if you've ever been sitting
out there gon be a writer just look like
one you can have your chance tonight if
you win this its cash value is pretty
high right about 200 bucks 200 dollar
cash value that's [ __ ] sweet and with
each winning package of course you're
gonna get this week's beautiful art
created by the great Nate himself Dark
Knight Returns look at that gorgeous
ship I've been begging JC forever the
proprietor of this year joint the scum
and villainy Kent's unit to take all of
Nate's posters and poster the bathroom
with them cool thing to do and now that
I've said it publicly we've shamed him
into doing so Jacy picks the people who
are gonna ask the questions so we turn
it over to you JC what do we got all
right I forgot to mention this before
the show started but I got this letter
from somebody back in November so
that'll be the first Q&A I'm gonna try
to go through because it's a long letter
and it didn't have anthrax in it so I
figure we could do it he says dear JC my
name is Jesse
Daisie included as a letter for mr.
Smith and Mark Bernard and I'm far too
poor to travel all the way to LA to ask
my question but it's something I
desperately have been wanting to ask
since my dad passed in March please give
the included letter for them to read on
the podcast QA I'm very appreciative and
then he sent me two dollars cash Wow
to do what yeah really to bribe me to
read this letter how do you know it's
not a buck for each of us I include what
little cash I have as compensation for
this it's American cash yeah it's two
he's from Iowa oh I think he's from
England he only sent two bucks well he's
a mailman so he he finds it ironic that
he's not delivering this in person but
the letter was kind of sweet so I'm
gonna try to fire try to get through it
here if you're reading this I'm very
surprised Thank You JC my name is Justin
Daisy from Ames Iowa that state that you
fly over I wish I could come to a live
show but as a mailman I don't make that
good a scratch to come out there my
father my father passed in March 2019
from a random heart attack his name is
Don Daisy he and I had our differences
and are very different people but we did
share a love of all things DC and Batman
his first tattoo was of the Batman
animated series logo his mother cried
for hours I was told and my first one
was of the Batman Beyond logo circle of
life huh like I said we didn't see eye
to eye on a lot but when I went off to
college life got better we did talk and
we both tried to connect with each other
I don't know how it came up but he found
out I listened to this podcast and while
he didn't understand he did recognize
who Kevin Smith was so for the last few
years we would chat about Kevin Smith
movies and news then he his question is
what is something your father taught you
that you still hold on to or appreciate
to this day and or what is something you
hope to pass on to your children and
that's
for both of you guys you wanna go first
yeah yeah I can go first my dad taught
me someone inadvertently that writing
was a job persons can have I went to go
see Flash Gordon at nine years old in
the theatre starring one Max von Sydow
and and there's the moment in Flash
Gordon where if you're not familiar with
it there on the planet are Bohr right
and like flashes kind of in disguise and
prints Baron's like oh I hate you
because I think or is all about you he's
like well I'm gonna rope you in with
these other young knuckleheads you're
gonna pass the trial of manhood and
become a full-blood or boring citizen
and they have the great stump in the
middle of this [ __ ] veranda I guess
on the planet or bored and the whole
jizz was jizz weird the gist
did you the gist was you know the young
guys would stick their hands in the
stomping inside the stuff that is weird
scorpion thing that would have will bite
you and you have to stick your hand and
leave it in there long enough if the
Scorpion decided that you were worthy
and didn't bite you you could be a man
and if it did the poison was lethal and
you would die in mere minutes that's
pretty much the gist pretty much the
gist and so you know you see one young
guy do it you see him get bitten so you
establish the the rules and then
flashsticks is hand in and I at nine
years old I'm on the edge of my [ __ ]
seat I'm like oh what the [ __ ] is about
to happen here I just saw a [ __ ]
die and your hero sticking his hand in
like no don't kill flashcard and my dad
means always goes don't worry they never
killed a hero and I was like who's this
vase [ __ ] there was a like wait this
isn't the movies just don't appear in
the world there they are made by people
like everything that you watch on TV is
the rest' a fault of a bunch of people
who made something and it was literally
the first time that I realized that this
was a job people had and it was a thing
that you do and that lots of people did
and and lots of people to different
things and then one of them was writer
and there are the people who never
killed a hero until they do in which
case it's awesome so that is the thing
that my dad taught me not on purpose it
wasn't like it come soon to my knee let
me expose there was a universe but he
did somehow also crack open the the
cheat code of the universe for me so
yeah and then the advice that you would
pass on as a parent the advice I would
hope to pass on as opposed that what it
was I thought it was and or but uh and
or will do the end state curious you
know like the the the peril of adulthood
is being stagnant you know it's it's
stopping to wonder why things work the
way they were
why how things happen what more you can
learn I remember watching an interview
with Harrison Ford I think was on
Letterman and he had the earring which
is done but he also just learned to fly
and he was like 72 years old and dave
was like why
and Harrison she said I had to learn
something new in a while and I wanted to
learn something new and he decided to
learn how to fly and just the that
keeping yourself curious about the world
and looking to learn new things I'm
looking to expose yourself to [ __ ] you
haven't ever before traveling meeting
people not being afraid being curious my
curiosity is is ultimately what drives
sort of ambition it's what drives it's
what drives and so do that very nice I
my the advice I didn't get advice from
my dad but what I got from my dad same
thing was inadvertent however made all
the difference I am my father's child
and I am why I am and who I am today
because of him and not because he tried
to shape that just because I got to
witness his life and he was the first
adult that I knew right him and mom so
they represented what it was going to be
to grow up one day that was the prime
example I saw every [ __ ] day we had
other people other adults in my life but
there was and my old man hated his
[ __ ] job hated it with a passion he
worked at the post office and he worked
so he worked he'd leave the house 10
o'clock at night start shift at 11
o'clock work till 7:00 in the morning
and then come home after that and stuff
and he hated his [ __ ] job with a
passion I've never seen anyone dislike a
function more than that like you know he
did it because that's what paid for his
family and [ __ ] but he wasn't from a
generation that was like what were your
ambitions what do you dream about doing
he dreamed about having a wife and kids
and he just had to pay for it so he got
a [ __ ] job and he couldn't stand it
every night of his life that he had to
work he did not want to go to work and
[ __ ] he was not a generally unhappy man
but at night he was cranky as [ __ ] man
and when I saw him his most relaxed and
his most joyous other than what I'm sure
my mother [ __ ] him because I didn't
see that but but I'm here so improved
that happened at least [ __ ] once I
was in a movie theater and he would take
me the movies all the time because
that's what he did with me like at one
point at a conversation with my mom he
was like I'm gonna do movies with the
fat one that's gonna be our thing and
[ __ ] and then he would take me to the
movies all the time and in the movies he
was happy like you know he'd escaped
they is exactly what they're there for
it's like that scene from Sullivan's
Travels he was a [ __ ] prisoner with a
sour puss on until the movie began and
then he was [ __ ] happy and [ __ ] like
that and it was never him gone you
should do this cuz we didn't come from
that [ __ ] world but that left an
impact to two things that I still to
this day believe in like [ __ ] movies
can save a life not physically but they
could save your sanity and don't ever
get a [ __ ] job ever
and so I've endeavored to not get a job
my whole [ __ ] life and in doing so
just made a bunch of [ __ ] movies so
he I don't know if he ever marked the
irony before he [ __ ] died but like I
told them at one point I was like you
know I do this because you used to take
me to the movies and he goes I didn't
take you to the movies like the con you
make
there was a point of pride to a point
yeah what advice would I give my kid
I've given her every piece of advice
unlike my father I tried to shape my
kids existence by giving her [ __ ]
lessons and [ __ ] like that mercifully
she chose like her own path and stuff
but the one piece of advice I always
thought was really useful was it came
later in life when she wanted to be an
actress and that's what she is now but
you know she she wound up getting in
Quentin's movie and she was so [ __ ]
over the moon about and [ __ ] and I was
like that's great
I'm so happy for you because you really
wanted this but you know like the reason
she got cast was because he had the
Manson kids come up with their own
monologues didn't give him pages to
audition with he's just like come up
with what you think your character would
say so she did a monologue that she
wrote and he [ __ ] liked it and cast
her he was like you know I like her
monologue I'm gonna find something for a
dumber write a part for her and so you
know she was like over the moon because
she got picked then I was like I get it
that's what every actor or actress lives
for that moment where you are the one
out of 200 [ __ ] people you got picked
that's great but what I heard in that
story was one of the greatest writers in
our business responded to something you
[ __ ] Road you wrote that monologue
and that's what got you [ __ ] hired
and stuff so lean into that like [ __ ]
write a script directing yourself
because like yes it's nice to get picked
by somebody else but you know you didn't
fall far from this [ __ ] tree man as
an apple and if I had waited for
somebody to pick me you wouldn't be
[ __ ] born I'd still be at a
convenience store in New Jersey Manson
it's nice to get picked but don't
[ __ ] spend your whole life waiting
for somebody to pick you pick your
[ __ ] self man and so she started
writing a script I felt really good
about that hopefully she'll write
herself a leading part and she'll direct
the [ __ ] thing man so that's that was
the best piece of advice that I as the
guy that I became in life could pass on
to her man which was like [ __ ] don't
wait there's no waiting no one is ever
coming to help and just because you're
good at something doesn't mean you'll
necessarily be rewarded with the [ __ ]
job so it's fun to go through the
process I would
imagine I don't know why any actor or
actress would ever subject themselves to
constant like auditions just hearing no
over and over again would be
soul-crushing to me that's why I did
what I did not because I'm like I was
visionary I was just like well I would
never get picked by anybody out so I'm
gonna [ __ ] pick myself and chart my
own [ __ ] course so that's what I'd
sell her pick yourself all right
that's to the person that's not here so
they don't get anything no we get
anything we dive into the questions
somebody explain this who brought the
bags with the books explain
I love these I've seen these before I'm
gonna hold them up this I got once years
ago at the upper-hand Hollywood
babble-on it then you got an evening at
the Opera House where was it Sydney
Australia had the Opera House at the
Opera House yeah but it wasn't bad
wasn't it with Babylon it was there just
me by myself it's amazing it's called
wookie erotica and it's only it is a
magazine like it's it's unbelievable
it's a Star Wars parody magazine is what
it builds itself as but it is so [ __ ]
authentic that I was like this is a real
[ __ ] thing and he was like no it says
parody right on it on the back there's
like a Smirnoff ad but it's smear Hoff
and it has the Wookiees arm cut off
holding a bottle of vodka
it is beyond [ __ ] brilliant this one
I've seen and there's there's also some
it's wookie erotica so they're not just
yes there's a lady here hold on I got to
show you this and you know [ __ ] for
people who might get easily offended
oh my avert your eyes there's a woman
with a gomorian guard mask on so it's
like a sexy gomorian guard from Return
of the Jedi well dude it's so brilliant
there's like some naked ladies also
boobies in it as well but it's like
playboy as if it was in yet our wars
universe so basically it's the idea if
it was if playboy existed it 1970s
playboy existed in this that was
universe and if I remember correctly
like why
did you do it you were hired you were
like every everything we gave you
tonight was made by me and Craig he my
business partner just because we want to
do it we just to do it yeah we just made
my own versions like Mark said earlier
just to do a different take on stuff
you're familiar with this one I haven't
seen know that that one I wanted to
bring that's the latest one that's the
sequel the latest it's boogie erotica
and it shows r2d2 lighting the cigarette
of of a lady who's you know it looks
exactly like a playboy it's so [ __ ]
wonderful yeah a lot of it we've
actually recreated of the original font
from the 70's and all their ads and
everything but everything's Wow Star
Wars despite that why don't we had to go
a bit deeper because we only referenced
the original kind of trilogy so there's
like there's an ad for a light a
landspeeder that looks [ __ ]
astounding man it's really great it
sounds really great what is now this is
new what is Sabre okay we made that and
we have a lot of female uncut stuff so
we made a male penis towards Sabre what
is it I'm sorry - male pinup calendar
for our female fans cheesecake for the
ladies this is tremendous [ __ ] yeah
we'll go to another random one let's see
what I mean like a lot of dudes holding
lightsabers very suggestively oh my god
but what what is it called the name of
this giant giant panda King Zhou company
is your company but again you do it for
fun yeah we just do for fun we do some
of them but most of it cuz we're just a
dude wait you do sell them yeah we do
someone on our website but yeah we do
people fun like please tell me everyone
buys them yeah they did they do good
because if when I first saw it I was
like this is ingenious but it was
described to me as a one-off I didn't
know that you actually saw it was maybe
it's in my library at home I passed this
every day good this is the unauthorized
detailed account of Gotham 1919 to 1939
and it's a bunch of photos that you guys
had to create everything in that book we
created you created everything and so
it's basically like it's it's crazy I
opened this book and I was like this
looks so expensive the Batmobile an old
star battle but you guys had to create
that she else tells that of a miniature
so we basically wanted to retell the
whole Kennan of Batman between the two
world wars and Caban real history weave
and Tweedledee and Tweedledum everybody
has a page and they're represented yeah
because they would be the big kick for
us was taking like characters like
bat-mite
and Twitter Dahmer Tweedledee and try
and make him realistic in a 19:20
setting and this you could set this
folks can buy this as well yep where do
they go
giant panda King Kong giant panda King
calm I I vouch for this [ __ ] I've seen
it in person and it is gobsmacking Lee
excellent done make incredible affection
and attention to detail
Wow this is crazy man when I looked in
the bag I said what brings you to town
um basically we've got we have to head
off to Vegas in a couple of days it's
going to make a few meetings there for a
project or working on but every time
we're in town if the shows on we always
try and make it and since the early days
of fat man on Batman and then fat man
Beyond I've always wanted to when I used
to listen to the show and it used to be
the old format always thought one day
I'm gonna get Kevin to talk about the
book I'm gonna talk about the book so
it's kind of a full circle thing it
really is what a self-fulfilling
prophecy man excellent [ __ ] give it
up for him and it's fantastic stuff well
part of me really wants to take those
wookie magazines and like drop them in
the woods somewhere
so like some enterprising young child
cuz that's how everybody else found
their porn when you're like 11 years old
like did you find us like a Playboy's in
the woods like yeah let's go back to the
woods
like a they don't have Playboy's and be
like we're scarce on woods like it would
be kind of nice just to like we're gonna
create some nerds and some men also also
see kids find porn at age six on the
Internet at this point so they won't
have to stumble over the what is this
artifact of a bygone age it is just
leave it buy it and leave it at a
doctor's office it would be such a
mindfuck people be like is this from
another dimension is this real what is
this when I was looking at I was like is
this a real [ __ ] thing even though
it's a parody on it it was so well done
um all right where we going JC's picking
people we got three people to go
we got Danny Redford Danny give it up
for Danny man all right Danny
how are you I'm stoked I'm from
Australia I'm just stoked to be know you
guys know each other makes me really
proud to be an Australian Wow what part
are you from I'm from Brisbane where are
you from Sydney Brisbane and how far you
guys are way far apart right so not
friends then that's what I always joy
did you come solo what are you doing
yeah me a solo just been in a Canada for
the last couple weeks snowboarding and
just got to LA last night the whole time
I was in Canada all I could think about
was your emo cab episodes and your
imitations of the Canadian days and was
I accurate I was [ __ ] great thank you
so I'm a massive Star Wars fan and with
massive Mandalorian fan and I think
Favreau's the the right guy to be
working on that it just feels like it's
coming from his heart and when I hear
you Marc talk about story and the way
you break down story
sometimes you're criticized I was a
little too much for me and that's why
I'm here tonight
yeah my goalie [ __ ] I'm the Ayatollah of
rock and roll I've been traveling I
brought the corona yeah I would love to
know what you guys would say how you
would break a story for Star Wars TV
show and who Jeff Carson ooh any Star
Wars TV show that's not about no no my
friend mundo you're a secretive fella
shout your name in the Bob [ __ ] Star
Wars show look if we want the show to
make money just call it baby Yoda and
[ __ ] feature show on him but they've
already got that gimmick gone I I was I
was quite taken with with Kara dune as a
character and I could I could see like
the gia Carano the super in shock
trooper I could see more stories with
her I could see her origin story I can I
think she's so [ __ ] badass that I
would watch a show about that character
and the thing is that that character has
gone through to get to where she is the
level of disillusionment like you've got
to believe at some point to enlist in
that squadron you know and then to have
that belief somehow hammered away from
you and leave her the way she is now and
then I mean the Mandalorian seems to be
partly at least about her arc towards
believing in something again maybe
that's something is mando maybe it's
baby Yoda maybe it's whatever but that
loss of faith I think is super
interesting especially in a in a show in
asada that is fundamentally kind of
about faith you know and what happens
when it's taken from you and who do you
choose to hate for it and that person is
probably yourself to a certain degree so
yeah I'd watch that show if they pay me
money for it nice I would go less
obscure I would just do a flat-out Darth
Vader show but Darth Vader the early
years so he's in the suit he's figuring
out how to be a Lord of the Sith it's
all the early stuff like somewhere
between the end of what was the last one
revenge of the Seth but before he
becomes like the badass from the road
one hallway scene
how does he become that badass that to
me is no brainer cuz you know [ __ ]
it's a dude in a mask like just like
Mandalorian he never takes that mask off
so pretty easy show to shoot I would I
would do that because that you know
[ __ ] he's key character and even
though he's like everybody thinks they
know and they haven't really even
scratched the [ __ ] surface
he's only truly been in a couple films
so you can really go deep down a well
with him I think and there was a thing I
saw recently online I don't read the
Star Wars comic books but I guess in
some recent one or some part of Canon is
that the sandpeople the Tusken Raiders
worship Darth Vader they did this in a
comic there's a gorgeous splash page of
this giant like Darth Vader statue and
all the Tusken Raiders bowing in front
of it and what I thought was medalist
[ __ ] about that was that they don't know
that [ __ ] he was Anakin Skywalker the
guy that came in and [ __ ] slaughtered
all the Tusken Raiders yeah the kids as
well so I thought that was cool so you
could do that like as one of the stories
and chef like because this is a guy
who's descending slowly into controlled
madness right like losing his humanity
physically he's lost his humanity is
encased in [ __ ] metal I don't know
something interesting to do there and he
is one of the most [ __ ] recognizable
villains of all time but like you could
spend I mean look we just did a whole
deep dive on Joker for two hours
[ __ ] won an Oscar and it made a
billion dollars I'm sure we can [ __ ]
find some shoe leather on Darth Vader
[ __ ] put together and do the same
thing that's [ __ ] dope cuz we answer
your question you have won a prize man
give it up for them you get to pick you
want tickets you want final draft or you
want the book the book poster in the
Batman book all yours
well done pleasure man welcome thank you
that question
[ __ ] yielded a great story sadly
nobody at home is gonna see it I know
what a grace I look forward to that [ __ ]
that's awesome all right JC [ __ ] that
was good that was real good man Brian
Wolfe see that could be on my [ __ ]
show see ya there you go sweet episode
the one everyone would talk about who we
going with Brian Wolfe
give it up for Brian everybody that's
the wipe down
what's up Bry hey it's so good where are
you from Philadelphia rigidly been here
for the last two years right Sean
McDonald man that [ __ ] song was about
the liberty bill is it really yeah
shouldn't sweet freedom this song from
running scared yeah is about the Liberty
Bell never know it would I didn't know
that follow that I have no idea so my
question is if you guys could choose one
item from any comic book universe can't
be like the mother box or like the
Infinity Gauntlet but from any hero
which would you choose and why to own
alright what any any item from the world
of comics but it's not a mother box and
not yeah it can't be like universe
altering reality bending done and done
but it could be like [ __ ] the helmet
of Naboo yeah [ __ ] it from dr. fate and
[ __ ] absolutely then the helmet of Naboo
from dr. fate um no I let me see what
would I want from comics the Iron Man
suit especially as featured in the
movies because he could literally step
out of it and then step into it [ __ ]
then I would also want somebody and
maintain it because I'm not smart like
him
or mechanical but the Ironman suit you
know or what did he call it it's not a
weapon it's a prosthetic it's a
high-tech prosthesis that seems like it
could do a bunch of [ __ ] [ __ ] number
one think of all the money you would
save on airfare like you just you're
flying everywhere and [ __ ] and then you
know there's you could jump into war
zones and [ __ ] take out tanks and
stuff and then also like remember in
eopns in iron man 2 he peed in it and it
all worked out you could wear it and it
would just take carry and stuff like a
giant diaper wow I'm not sure I can beat
the giant diaper and it can't be
universe altering so like there's no
Infinity Gauntlet
yeah no infinity none of the stones you
can have the I about one of the stones I
know if I'm imaginative enough can it be
a living thing
what's it can't be a living thing or a
tech it's got to be tech like this
Lockheed the dragon I was gonna do that
I got yeah I guess so we're go to get go
breaking the rules I want and it's gonna
sound pervy but I want cerebro and
cerebro is not world or altering it just
magnifies the where's right I mean I
suppose I would also need to be Charles
Xavier you need to be a mutant so maybe
that sucks sure though that I asked for
sorry bro this big thing is the size of
a room did you ever the [ __ ] keys for
man ooh
no the Danger Room oh yeah I'm on the
danger not for danger purposes but you
just feel like kick-ass party purposes
like it's use your own [ __ ] holodeck
like I don't need to actually have
robots kill me like we you just have a
really good time [ __ ] that we'd be
making the cheapest movies in the world
man
because I'd be like today we're gonna
fight a transformer and the [ __ ]
danger and makes a transformer we just
roll cameras on that [ __ ]
it's the Danger Room is literally the
[ __ ] volume they shot the Mandalorian
did you see that footage I saw that wall
in real life oh we're working on the
Disney when we were working on the
potential Disney Plus show Kingdom
Keepers they brought me in for a like a
tech day and they were like this wall
here can duplicate any [ __ ]
background and I footage on one of my
phones if like shooting the wall when
you move from side to side it moves and
creates depth and stuff so when I saw
that behind the scenes on Mandalorian
thing I was like oh my god they're using
that [ __ ] wall Wow it's it's the same
the idea was in Mission Impossible one
of them where it's that scene where
they're walking down a hallway and so
they put up this screen that is Ghost
Protocol well done we're like it's keyed
into the perspective of the dude at the
end of it it's time he moves the image
moves with him they just stole that and
made a [ __ ] room I made it for real
yeah way to go guys I'd have also liked
the not exact but the pseudo science
behind Invisible Man
- is it yeah what the like he's
brilliant in optics and I was like what
a cop-out that is but then when they did
it I was like oh [ __ ] he is brilliant in
optics I was just so glad it wasn't like
I [ __ ] create a potion and I couldn't
[ __ ] like it made sense where I was like
holy [ __ ] like that makes sense in a
weird sci-fi tech way okay I'll buy it
but yes I want the Danger Room you get
the Danger Room and what did I choose
the Iron Man convinces the Iron Man suit
yeah I guess that over the Batmobile
Batmobile just does one thing right and
probably looks like a gas guzzler [ __ ]
that the Iron Man suits run by an arc
reactor so there's it's like free cheap
energy and [ __ ] right do I get the arc
reactor with the suit or just the suit
isn't any one of these like deals with
the devil thing where's like you didn't
say specifically
having a big suit that don't work ain't
gonna [ __ ] like do me anything but
it's the whole deal oh yeah the whole
deal it wouldn't work out I'm in sued
and I never would have said that's how
good those [ __ ] movies are because I
never in a million years would have ever
picked that my entire life before those
[ __ ] Marvel movies but now having
seen the Iron Man suit work over and
over again and I want the the one that
he walks in I don't want that nanobyte
[ __ ]
I'd like the little [ __ ] where it
spreads across you I liked like remember
and like he did it a lot in Iron Man 3
but in a Voltron like when they get to
the to the strucker's place in the
beginning and he steps out of the seat
suit and he's like sentry mode and then
it just goes back and that's cool that's
the [ __ ] version of the studio want
me parmi also wants the expensive
versions the the classic Nick Fury
flying car yeah like that would be cool
then why not get the fantastic car at
that point because Reed Richards built
that fast [ __ ] shield man you never know
who's running shield that could be the
Reed Richards man you count on him how
about those answers they work yeah they
work [ __ ] that man you win pick ax
give it up farm man I was fun you get
either the free tickets to the movies or
the final draft [ __ ] I and you get a
new poster give it up Fermi's winner
well done thank you do we have the
tickets these must be those are tickets
so is the tickets all right here we go
man last question of the night is Cindy
who is it
Cindy everyone give it up whoo Cindy CIN
CIN d70 give it up Cindy ladies a job
[Music]
Sandee that is an amazing shirt can we
just take a peek real quick we're from
DC gorgeous this is Jim Lee rendition oh
yeah [ __ ] that's nice
badass appreciate it um all right so my
question is is this kind of a heavy one
so who is your favorite Batman villain
and why mine's always been mr. freeze
people usually go for the Joker because
that's like always a straightforward
go-to but when I think of like a
favorite villain like in like relate
with Mr Freeze always been like on my
top list I was wondering who you guys
would choose as your favorite villain
and why is your mr. freeze predicated on
the Batman animated series that horse
yes Paul D and then also like Paul Dini
helped write the Arkham series yes and
in Arkham Knight they really wrap that
up nicely and it's a really big like arc
that he has and I really enjoyed that so
I always thought that was a really good
story so when we did that's the that's
the difference a brilliant writer can
make with like a character prior to him
touching mr. freeze mr. freeze was like
you know and also Ram you never thought
it was oh he wears that helmet [ __ ] and
[ __ ] from the Batman TV show there
was that one episode remember where he
was sitting at a [ __ ] frozen room and
he wanted like who ever wanted to like
sit with him had to walk between like
they had these red lights that would
like heat the panel so they could come
sit next don't you it was all corny Paul
turned it into like something beautiful
tragic heartbreaking one can relate to
the [ __ ] villain at the same time as
like despise himself
yeah that's he [ __ ] what an artist I
think about think about how many people
now know the character as that character
because that guy laid hands on the
character that's transformed it alright
you wanna go first or me I'm gonna let
you close it out I I was not a Batman
fan I think that Batman was down my
entree right into into comic books I was
a Marvel kid I was
he's an x-man kid of the spider-man kid
and then Dark Knight Returns came out
and I was like oh [ __ ] I need to pick
this up like it was that and Watchmen at
the same time like he brought me over to
DC the book Dark Knight Returns yes
returns and watch man probably converted
a lot of people to bat it really did
that was it was the entry vector for
Batman and then I got to be a Batman fan
and then I read I want to say was son of
the demon maybe it was a big like
[ __ ] hardcover like Mike barbar and
that was my first exposure to racy al
Ghul and and it was the first time I'd
heard Batman referred to as the
detective yes you know he was just a
hello detective he's the detective of
course and I loved that character
I loved that sort of the the the overly
moral but totally skewed version of the
world that he had it was I want to make
it better
essentially cinematic Thanos is kind of
like a jewel because Thanos and the
comics wasn't like oh I want to kill
half the universe to save it he was like
I want to do it to impress death because
I love death like death the lady dead so
they kind of borrowed more of the noble
villain approach of like I just want to
you know if I can save the universe by
getting rid of half somebody has to make
the hard decisions right and that was
ratio cool I was very shocked I mean I
loved his his desires to to confound his
own humanity like he realized that like
I I can't live forever I want to live
forever let me solve the forever problem
and here's like I I just really was
taken by because I the Batman that I
knew before that was very much the Adam
West Batman and then the sort of
animated series Batman I would come to
after that but it looks so much it was
jokey so much it was silly and the
villains were always kind of silly but
that dude was for real and that dude had
an agenda and he loved Batman in a
weird-ass sort of way yeah they were
equals it was very much respected the
[ __ ] out of him it was Moriarty in
Sherlock yes oh my god that's all it was
my whole life I was like what an
original relationship but you're right
it's
Sherlock Holmes and Moriarty you know
and so I love the feeling of coming at
Batman from that angle which had never
come to me that way and of course his
arch-nemesis in that story would be also
on that same plane and so getting to
Batman the detective getting to that
level of investment in that character
like if only he would agree with him man
we could do great things right and
that's what that's why I always liked
like the Batman villains when they're so
personable and like they're very
attached to their goal and how they see
the world those are always the best
villains to me and I feel like even in a
cinematic point of view they haven't
even scratched the surface like you got
man-bat you have Clayface Mr Freeze
hasn't been done justice all these
villains like haven't even begun to been
able to cover like how Batman stories
can be told from a villains point of
view which makes them that much better
because Batman is the same way they are
he's just on the good side of things
like like a bad guys own agenda yeah
every Batman villain is reflecting a
version of either Bruce Wayne or Batman
right I gotta and I thought that the the
parallels between the two there were
particularly stark for me I like the
Joker as much as anybody else but I had
never understood why you know that's the
opposite of a bad as a clown what like
it's great character but he was not the
one that you know when I think a Batman
I I don't immediately go to Joker in
terms of stuff that I think about like
who Batman who's Batman is villain for
me I don't I honestly don't know because
I was thinking about it while Mark was
talking and it's not even like oh he
took my answer I don't know who my
favorite bat villain is and who's the
one that means the most to me or who's
the one that I could do the most with if
I ever like tried to play with the
character let me think
what's not
I mean I like the Catwoman character
poison ivy is always interesting I think
and when I when I like this is gonna be
a weak answer but when I wrote Batman
one of my favorite characters to write
him with was poison ivy and not just
because like she [ __ ] used THC to
knock him out she got him high on sugar
which I thought was fun I was like
nobody's done that yet easy pickings but
just the I I like their interplay how
you know it's not just the like she's
incredibly sexualized or something like
that
she's brilliant like she's a you know in
some ways kind of like cheetah like you
know Minerva herself like a scientist
who took it too [ __ ] far depending on
which our incarnation you do but I don't
know that's not even my favs not
Catwoman not Riddler although I've read
some wonderful Riddler stories not
penguin although that would have been
the easy go to back in the day Harvey
Dent is interesting yeah
two-face when done well I think the best
he's ever been done was probably by
Frank Miller and Dark Knight Returns
because that's what got me interested in
in Harvey Dent as a character reading
that book and being like what the [ __ ]
like just the notion that and it was a
wonderful twisted notion that Frank
Miller played with that he was fixed
that all of the damage was gone and he
looked normal if not beautiful
but he like there's that beautiful panel
switch where he's like talking to Batman
and going like it's a mockery it's a
joke and blah blah blah and all these
things and Batman's internalist like I
finally see him the way he is and he
goes from the same shot of him looking
like a normal human to him being blown
out like in his head Harvey Dent
will even if they repair him he's so
[ __ ] deeply scarred that he is
two-faced forever I thought that was a
really compelling notion I liked that
character a bunch I've never really
[ __ ] with them though whenever I did
comics but maybe it might be Harvey Dent
might be two-faced especially because
there's this bittersweet nature to there
relationship they work together like
they were both on the side of justice
and also there's a bit of like I mean
he's kind of gone off the deep end and
he becomes a criminal and stuff but
here's an example of a guy who knows the
system as well and has just realized
that like the system's [ __ ] in a very
similar way that Batman has realized
that the system is [ __ ] and raised
about it I always I always thought of
Harvey as like a b-list Batman like he
didn't have the same money but he would
still had that duality and especially
that line they have in Dark Knight when
he says he says to him oh I hear they
have a different name for me and MCU
he's ago I don't know what that would be
but they call him already Harvey
two-face yeah like they already call him
that so I always like that like he
always had that duality until and they
didn't really I mean Chris Nolan goes
without saying did a rendition of that
character and Aaron Eckhart was
wonderful playing the role but you know
there weren't many times they [ __ ]
with that character in media beyond the
page right Tommy Lee Jones did him in a
very over-the-top fashion but then of
course wasn't Richard Maul is probably
the most famous one and the most
touching one from the batman the
animated series like that initial first
arc that took Harvey Dent intellect to
face right territory which is such a
great [ __ ] time but I think Aaron
Eckhart like elevated as did Chris Nolan
and did he write that by himself or his
brother helped and what's his name and
where their take on the character I
thought it was really great and tragic
and wonderful I got one more thought
yeah go Joe Chill the ultimate Batman
villain you're that like villain without
whom there is no Batman whatsoever and
the one he'll never catch the one who'll
never put in Arkham the one he'll never
stopped from doing anything else cuz
he's done everything you possibly do mmm
we need a movie like that get away from
the Joker's yeah what a satisfying movie
that was fine didn't [ __ ] solve the
crime at the killer credits
a good enough answer yeah I could give
it up from history to watch it ladies
gentlemen you win the tickets and the
poster god damn pleasuring man that was
fun I forgot how fun it is to kind of do
the what if some [ __ ] like that fall
down a rabbit hole oh my god
like this world in about three weeks
when the corona virus kills us all the
show is at an end ladies and gentlemen
have you enjoyed yourself this week do
you have a good time so lovely to be
back thanks for everyone who came out to
be with us here tonight man
but of course big thanks to God standing
next to me who not only held down the
fort and stuff while I was away
but as even improved at his job since I
forgot your [ __ ] sharp give it up for
the fabulous mr. mark Bernard in or
should I say p-cards mark we are doing
this again when it's not next week but
it's the 24th 24th so if you want to get
tickets for it they'll be sure they're
online right now if you're in the Los
Angeles area today is what Tuesday
Wednesday Tuesday Tuesday on Friday I'm
in Hollywood on Melrose at the shag
store doing a signing of the print that
he did the Jay and Silent Bob print we
did a signing down at the Palm Springs
store a couple months ago now we're
doing it here in town y'all are welcome
to come and stuff even feeling buy
anything come hang out
Stewart's [ __ ] beautiful and [ __ ] but
I guarantee you it's tough to walk out
of that place without buying something
his artwork is really nice and the print
he did for Jay and Silent Bob is
breathtaking so I'm doing that on
[ __ ] Friday Mark's series is already
sold out so you sold out but we'll have
another one in May and look for that and
then I think Hollywood babble-on I'm
getting back to at the end of this month
and Oxnard so if you're into that
check out tickets at cease mod.com as
always ladies and gentlemen this is the
greatest watering hole on the planet man
scum and villainy Cantina JC runs a hell
of a shop here give it up for buggin
Jason
and thank all of you at home and
cellphone patiently waiting laws off on
tour I'm back now so we'll be doing this
much more regular and there's so much
[ __ ] news to cover all the time it's
happening so [ __ ] fast can't wait to
cover it all with you I looked forward
to coming here while I was on tour I was
like once tour is gonna suck when it's
all over it's gonna suck but I knew I
come here and I get to do a variation of
the same [ __ ] I was doing there the
whole time
so it's almost like coming home thank
you for giving me a home to come home to
ladies and gentlemen ah
that being said [ __ ] I forget how we
finished the [ __ ] show it's been so
long I say we'll give it up for mark
barnard and and that's it for fat man be
on ladies and gentlemen tune in next
time same fat time same fat channel
smart kefka more youtube.com slash Kevin
Smith for the good of all three good eye
[Applause]
[Music]
you